AFTERNOON A RESPONSE CODE
NINETEEN EMERGENCY. TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN
ADDITION TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS
MANY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR. IN THIS CASE LEAD
WITNESSES ONE OF TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS AND THERE IS
NO RESERVING TIME FOR OTHER
WITNESSES. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN THIS LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. FOR THESE WITNESSES
WILL BE A LIMIT OF TEN MINUTES
FOR SUPPORT. IN TEN MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO DIFFERENT
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. IT WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE OF IS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TESTIFIED
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. IN I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO.
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT
NINE THREE FOUR ZERO SIX ONE.
EIGHT NINE THREE FOUR ZERO SIX
ONE. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TOTAL COMFORT SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE. THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WE PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOU MY NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU WERE
NOT READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
PROPERLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST. MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING. AS
IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEANS
SERVICE. RATHER CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WELL EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HIRING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MATTERS AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO THE
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE PATIENT
AND RESPECTFUL SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE TEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BEFORE YOUR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S.
CLOSEST TELEVISION QUORUM. THE
MINIMUM ASK A CONSULTANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CORTEZ A- UNDER- CHAU BUG HERE
SENATOR DORADO. SENATOR LAYERED
DEAR SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO OF A QUORUM- I
WOULD LIKE TO JUST BEFORE WE
TAKE UP OUR FIRST OFTEN I SEE
THE FILM CINDERELLA THIS YEAR I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE UP. OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON CONSENT. CONSENT HAS
BEEN MOVED ANY DISCUSSION NO
IT'S REQUESTED A CONSENT UNDER
TO BE PULLED THERE WERE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT FOR THE
RECORD. SB THREE NINETY AND SB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE. OF WITH THAT
WE WILL ASK FOR. A ROLL CALL
VOTE. SENATOR CORTEZ A HI. IN
ORDER JOE BURKE HI SENATOR
DORADO HI SENATOR LAYERED BY
SENATOR NEWMAN HI. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED BY A
UNANIMOUS VOTE FIVE TO ZERO SO
THOSE BILLS ARE A- NOW WE WILL
COME BACK TO OUR FIRST AUTHOR-
LET E JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET
AGAIN ONE MORE TIME. I'M SORRY
ONE MORE DISCLAIMER BEFORE WE
PROCEED- SENATOR ALAN AND THAT
IS SO THAT AT SOME POINT HERE-
IN THE PROCEEDINGS TODAY I WILL
HAVE TO GET UP AND LEAVE TO
PRESENT. IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
THAT'S MEETING FIVE
CONCURRENTLY WITH US- AND I
KNOW A LOT ABOUT IT BUT I SURE
WILL TAKE OVER SHARE IN MY
ABSENCE ON MOSTLY STATING THAT-
FOR PUBLIC PURPOSES. PEOPLE SEE
ME GET UP AND LEAVE. OF FOR
SOME LINCOLN UNTIL I COME BACK-
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WITH
THAT. HI. THERE WE WILL COME
BACK NOW. TO SENATOR ON FIVE AM
GOING TO YOU TO OF COMMITTEE TO
MOVE MY BILL WHICH IS TO BE
CHRIS IN THIS COMMITTEE SB FOUR
ALTHOUGH OR FOUR ONE- LAST ON
THE- AT THIS POINT THAT- I AM-
ANOTHER CONFLICT BETWEEN THE
TWO COMMITTEES IN TERMS OF THE
TWO PRESENTATIONS- WITH THAT
SAID- THERE'S NO OBJECTION WILL
PROCEED WITH THE GENDER THAT
WAY I'M SEEING CONCURRENCE FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. NOW FINALLY
SENATOR OWN- FALL STARTS ON MY
PART BUT- HERE WELCOME TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCHER
AND IF YOU DO GET UP DURING MY
PRESENTATION I WILL TRY NOT TO
BE. TOO SAD- BUT- I DO WANT TO
THANK. THE COMMITTEE FOR- FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR HELP AND FOR THE
SEX ANALYSIS- AND I APPRECIATE
THE- WORKING WITH YOU AND WITH
YOUR- WITH YOUR EXCELLENT STAFF
ON ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
BILL. THE GOLDEN STATE'S TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR
CREATIVE ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST
IN THE WORLD. YET AS WE NOW
COVER. NINETY NINETEEN BROUGHT
MUCH OF IT TOO IT STANDS STILL.
HI ACCORDING TO AMERICANS FOR
THE ARTS NINETY SIX PERCENT.
96% OF CREATIVE WORKERS NEARLY
EVERY CREATIVE WORKER BASICALLY
HAS LOST REVENUE. MORE
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. OTHER OVER THERE IS
THERE ARE OVER SEVEN OR SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND CREATED WORKERS.
IN CALIFORNIA- ABOUT HALF A
MILLION OF WHOM. ARE CURRENTLY
UNEMPLOYED. TO THE PANDEMIC. SO
OUR RECOVERY WILL DEPEND ON
MANY PEOPLE RETURNING TO WORK
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND OF
COURSE ISN'T JUST. AN ISSUE OF.
OF JOBS IT'S ALSO AN ISSUE. OF
OUR ABILITY TO BOUNCE BACK- YOU
KNOW FROM TO THE PANDEMIC IN
YOU KNOW MORE SOULFUL MANNER IN
A WAY THAT HELPS US HEAL. SO SO
THIS BILL IS THE CREATIVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ACT IT
WOULD DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD IN%
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO
ESTABLISH AND EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAM. IN CONSULTATION WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A COMMUNITY
NONPROFITS TO EMPLOYEE CREATED
WORKERS. IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WOULD ALSO ESTABLISH A TRAINING
PROGRAM THAT WOULD FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING MARKETABLE SKILLS IN
THE ARTS WITH PARTICULAR
PRIVATIZATION FOR LOW INCOME.
UNEMPLOYED AND DISADVANTAGED
PERSONS BEGINNING THEIR CAREERS
IN THE CREATIVE ARTS. AND HERE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT OUR
JULIE BAKER FROM CALIFORNIA
ARTS ADVOCATES. ANGLE STUBBLE
HERRERA FROM ARTS FOR LA.
PLEASE HOLD WHILE WE TRANSFER
YOUR CALL FOR ASSISTANCE. THE
ROAD IS THAT WHO YOU'RE YOU'RE
OPENING. I JUST KNOW WE WERE
INTERRUPTED BY THE- WELL I'LL
DO SYSTEM I WAS AYE AYE AYES
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO GET THE
TWO SPEAKERS AT YES I WAS JUST
ABOUT THE CALL ON YOUR- ON YOUR
LEAD SPEAKERS BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU ARE YES YES NOT
ONLY COMPLETED YOUR PORTION OF
THE PRESENTATION YES- IN A
GIVEN THE LEAD SUPPORT. ON THE
BILL- JULIE BAKER AND GUSTAVO
HERRERA- I GUESS SHE WAS LISTED.
FORCES JULIE BILL. YEAH
CHARACTER DATA CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE PRESS ON I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HEARD DISCLAIMER MY
REPEATED A CALL TIMES THE
MEETING. IKNOW. COME ON
GRADUALLY SOMETIMES- WE- HAVE
LIMITED LIMITED PUBLIC COMMENT
TO TWO MINUTES APPROVED LEAD
WITNESS. EACH IN APPRECIATE YOU
TRYING TO STAY WITHIN THAT TIME
FRAME THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
THAT HELPED PUT THIS TOGETHER
MY NAME IS JULIE BAKER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
ARTS ADVOCATES. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE. PART OF
SB SIX TWENTY ADULT CALIFORNIA
OUR TOPIC IT'S JUST PROUD TO
SPONSOR. SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
HELPS TO SOLVE SEVERAL
PROBLEMS. THAT ADDRESSES AN
URGENT NEED FOR JOBS IN THE
CREATIVE FACTORS SHROUDS CENTER
ALLEN SPOKE ARTIST GREAT
WORKERS IN CULTURE
ORGANIZATIONS WERE AMONG THE
FIRST IN THE HARDEST HIT I CODE
NINETEEN. AND ITS ATTENDANT
ECONOMIC IMPACT THIS IS A
SPECIALLY TRUE FOR BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
CREATED. MORE OFTEN UNDERSERVED
AND UNDER INVESTED IN PRIOR TO
PANDEMIC. BY CREATING JOBS ARE
THESE IMPACTED WORKERS
ORGANIZATION. LOCKER TO
DEDICATE THE FINANCIAL ARMED
INDIVIDUALS IN THE CREATIVE
SECTOR THE URGENT COMMUNITY
NEEDS THAT EMERGE THROUGHOUT
THE LAST YEAR. ITALY THE
FOUNDATION FOR MORE EQUITABLE
INCLUSIVE THE CREATIVE ECONOMY.
THE SECOND ISSUE CALLED IT
REPRESENTS AN INNOVATIVE
SOLUTION TO HELP BUILD BACK THE
RP CREATIVE INDUSTRIES. BY
OFFERING WORKPLACE DEVELOPMENT
FOR NEW PIPELINE AGREED
WORKERS. THE PROLONGED CLOSURES
HAVE BEEN DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
TRUCKERS MORE THAN JUST INCOME
LONG IN OUR OWN SURVEY AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY OF CLOSE
TO ONE THOUSAND ARTWORK WITH
THE BROADER IMPACT OF THE
PROLONGED SHUTDOWN SCHMIDT
THAT. 43% OF THE ORDER SURVEYS
WERE RECONSIDERING CREATIVE
WORK AND 20% WERE CONSIDERING
LEAVING THE STATE SHOULD WE
DON'T LOOK TO REBUILD THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES PIPELINE
CALIFORNIA COULD BE FACING A
CULTURAL TO PRESSURE. WE OFTEN
A CREATIVE SKILLS CREATIVITY
SKILLS ARE CRITICAL TO THE
FUTURE OF WORK ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY NINETEEN REGION
BEHAVIORAL THAT EACH STUDY
CREATIVITY. IN THE MAILBOX
GUILT. IN SHORT SUPPLY. TWENTY
AND DEVELOPMENT PRESCRIBE SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE TO BE. OF THE CALL THE
GRAY PARKS LOSING STUDENTS
VETERANS ARE. TO AMONG OTHERS
ABOUT ON BUILDING MARK ABOUT.
WE ARE CREATE AN- ORDERS ARE.
CALLED ON A TERMS OF CRISIS
THEY WERE. TO BRING IT BACK
FOR. TO THREE YEAR CAN YOU.
CONNECT AND HOPE. OUR WE CAN
THANK AND GIVE A- OF. THE NOT
BAD TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE LIVING
WAY WORKER. SRI NEED TO AND THE
PARADIGM AND ROMANCE. OF THE
STARTING. THE SUPPORT THE
YOU'RE UP THRIVING. YOU STILL
HAVE TO STOP ARTISTS WORKERS
BUT THERE. BETTER TRADE TAKES
FROM COMMITTEE AND RIGOR TO
SUPPLY WHICH IS VALUABLE. AND
SHOULD BE AS A- WORK ARTIST
SECOND. WE NEED THEM TO HELP
BRING. EMOTIONAL WELL COMMUNITY
COHESION. JOHN I CAN BE ON MY-
AND COMMUNITY. THIS. PUBLISHING
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIBLE. ACT
COULD HELP IN A LOT. POSITION
OTHER WORDS INTEREST PARTNER
TO. AS WELL PRETTY MUCH MENTAL
HEALTH BENEFITS ARE EVERY OUR
LIVES THANK YOU AND I'M- ABLE
TO AFTER QUESTIONS. TRY TO GET.
DAISY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS GUSTAVO
AND THAT AND THEN THE EXECUTIVE%
DIRECTOR OF ARTS FOR LA. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
TO EIGHT A BILL THAT ARE TRULY
IS ALSO PROUD TO SPONSOR. SB
SIX TO EIGHT AND LONG OVERDUE
AND WE DEEPLY APPRECIATE CENTER
ALLEN'S LEADERSHIP IN YOUR
PRIORITIZE ATION. OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY SENATE
LABOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
THE SON OF CHIU SALVADORAN
IMMIGRANTS I GREW UP IN LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND SILVER LAKE.
AND NEIGHBORHOOD IN EAST
CENTRAL LA. GROWING UP A
CREATIVE CAREER WITH NEVER
DISCUSSED AS A POTENTIAL CAREER
IN MY HOUSEHOLD. IN ARTS
EDUCATION WAS NOT OFFERED IN MY
SCHOOL I CAN TELL YOU THIS IS
STILL THE REALITY FOR MILLIONS
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
BURSTING WITH CREATIVITY. AND
GROWING UP IN LOW INCOME UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES TODAY. AT
A TIME OF DEVASTATING JOB
LOSSES IN THE CREATIVE SECTOR
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC WE MUST
EXPAND. EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE
CREATIVE SPECTRUM IN A WAY THAT
BENEFITS THE ECONOMY AND
CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA. CRISES
CAN WORSEN PRE EXISTING
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES. AND WE
KNOW THIS TO BE TRUE FROM OUR
PARTNERS IN THE CLIMATE CRISES
MOVEMENT. SB SIX TO EIGHT THE
STEP FORWARD TOWARDS ENSURING
THE JOBS RECOVERY FOR
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT ONE IN
SEVEN JOBS IN THE ALLEY REGION
OR IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY. IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND JOBS WERE
LOST YEAR IN LA. BUT THE
DEVASTATION WOULD NOT EQUAL THE
EXPERIENCE AS AN EXAMPLE YOU
KNOW BLACK ARTS WORKERS
EXPERIENCED THE LOSS OF INCOME.
AT DISPROPORTIONATE LEVELS
COMPARED TO OTHER GROUPS.
FEDERAL LEAF HAS BEEN A
LIFELINE FOR CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
UNEMPLOYMENT RELIEF FOR THE-
SELF EMPLOYED. BUT WE KNOW THAT
BY PARK ORGANIZATIONS AND
WORKERS WERE DECLINED ACCESS
THE FEDERAL RELIEF AT A HIGHER
RATE. SB SIX TO EIGHT ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA PRIORITIZE THE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CREATIVE
SECTOR JOBS. IT OFFERS TARGETED
JOB TRAINING FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY CENTER FIELD AND
PRIORITIZES THE LIVING WAGE TO
BREAK THE CYCLE IN THAT
INEQUALITY FOR MANY. THIS BILL
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA TO WRITE
STRONGER FROM THE IMPACT OF
KOBE NINETEEN. AND OPERATE JUST
RECOVER RE FOR ALL CHILD. THANK
YOU. FOUR THREE YOU- WILL KNOW
TO WITH SUPPORT WITNESSES OF
COMING TO THE CA OR THE SEVENTY
ONE HERE WHO WAS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT.
OF IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. THE
CITY NONE I WILL GO TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM VISITS SEE NO
WHEN THEY'RE WISHING TO TESTIFY
WILL MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. BUT IN ASK BROWN TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES WOULD APPRECIATE. AN
APPROXIMATION OF HOW MANY ARE
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES ARE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND WE WILL IDENTIFY YOU
BY THAT LINE NUMBER WHEN WE
OPEN YOUR LINE. IF USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE UP PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET AND MAKE SURE YOUR
PHONE IS A NEEDED BEFORE YOU
PRESS ANY BUTTONS. WE DO HAVE
ONE LIGHTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
LINE NUMBER. WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE GO AHEAD. IF ANY
MOCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS IN SUPPORT SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE MODERATOR. THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU- WE WILL MOVE
TO- OPPOSITION WITH WITNESSES I
SEE NO LEAD OPPOSITION. WHAT
ELSE CHARACTERS ANYONE HERE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHICH WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. ASSENAGON COME
FORWARD IT WILL LOOK TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM. AT SEA NO ONE
THERE WE WILL COME BACK TO THE
CAPITAL COVERED SERVICE AND
ASKED THE MODERATOR TO QUEUE
UP. ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT AND AGAIN
WOULD APPRECIATE. AN
APPROXIMATE NUMBER. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WE HAVE LOW AND KEEPING UP IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PROCEED.
OKAY THANK YOU- MODERATOR WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BEFORE YOU THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE. PLEASE BUT
YES CENTER NEWMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SHIPCENTER ALLEN DIED
THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL. I
COMMEND YOU FOR BEING A FORTY
AYE I THINK THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTELY APPROPRIATE- AND
POTENTIALLY REALLY EFFECTIVE
USE OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DOLLARS- AND AT THE PROPER TIME
I LIKE TO. MOVE THIS BILL BUT
ALSO HAS TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AS IT MOVES FORWARD FOR
THE SENATE. OKAY AND ON TO SEE
DRAW. THANK YOU- I TO THINK SIX
GREAT IDEA TO APPLY THE- TO THE
CREATIVE ALL WORKERS OF
CALIFORNIA- AND I SEE SOMEWHERE
REFERENCE EITHER IN THE
ANALYSIS- I DON'T KNOW IF IN
THE BILL TO THE HIGHROAD
PARTNERSHIPS- THAT EXIST WITH
THE STATE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- I THINK THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT. WHEN WE
CREATE SOMETHING LIKE THIS THAT
IT HAVE THAT REFERENCE TO
HARDWOOD PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE
THEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH EMPLOYERS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PARTNERSHIP THAT. WORD THE
CREATED WORKERS THEMSELVES LIKE
YOU SAID TARGETING- FROM
TARGETING COMMUNITIES OF FOR
RECRUITMENT AND FOR TRAINING
FOR APPRENTICES SO- HIRA
PARTNERSHIPS HAVE ALL THOSE
ELEMENTS AND- I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. FOR US TO
HAVE. THAT INTO EVERY IMPORTANT
SECTOR OF THE INDUSTRY AND IN
THE IN THE STATE SO I THINK
IT'S GREAT- BE CURIOUS TO SEE
IF OF REACHED OUT TO ANY OF
THE- CREATIVE UNIONS TO SAG
AFTRA OR ACTORS EQUITY AND
HOPEFULLY THAT THEY'RE AS MUCH
A PARTNER IN THIS TO MAKE IT
SUCCESSFUL AS AS OTHER PARTNERS.
THANK YOU WE HAVE WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AND- THEIR THEIR
ON GOING AND WITHOUT ACTUALLY
WANT TO BRING THEM IN- YOU
KNOW- IT'S MINOR YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE SO HELPFUL THEY'RE GONNA
COME OUT AND SUPPORT BELIEVE
WE'VE ALREADY HAD THE FLU
STARTED A CONVERSATION ABOUT.
OKAY TO PROVE THERE'S NOTHING
ALSO AND WE WILL GO BACK TO
SENATOR OWN CAREER OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE. APPRECIATE THE FOCUS
INFRASTRUCTURE YOUR THAT AWFUL
READING OF THE BILL- YEAH WE
ARE INSPIRED IN SOME RESPECTS.
I'M STANDING HERE LOOKING AT
THIS BEAUTIFUL WORKS PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION- WORK OF ART AND.
AND IN MANY RESPECTS THIS BILL
IS INSPIRED BY- BYE THAT YOU
CAN. I ENDEAVOR BY OUR
FOREBEARS. WHO TOOK A CRISIS AS
A MOMENT TO INVEST IN THE ARTS
AND CREATIVE. PEOPLE WHO HELPED
US BETTER INTERPRET. AND THEN
OF COURSE EMERGE. HI AND A
HEALTHIER MANNER FROM NOT THAT
TERRIBLE CRISIS THAT WE
SUFFERED THROUGH THE DEPRESSION
SO. IT'S IN THAT SPIRIT THE
LAST YEAR I VOTE TODAY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU BYE NOTE THAT
THERE IS A MOTION FROM CENTER
NEWMAN OR INTENTION TO MOVE THE
BILL. YES IT IS MOVED- ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION SEE NONE
WILL COME BACK TO- PART
COMMITTEE CONSOLE MEN ASK FOR A
ROLL CALL VOTE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
C. HI. SENATOR CORTEZ THE AYE
SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE HI FULLER A
CHOKE HI SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR TORONTO HI CENTER
LAYERED HI SENATOR LAYERED HI
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE SENATOR
NEWMAN HI. MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE VOTE WAS FIVE TWO
ZERO- IT WAS UNANIMOUS IN THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU. AS
PREVIOUSLY NOTED- WE'RE GOING
TO PASS ON S. B. FOR ELEVEN
WHICH IS MY BILL UNTIL THE END
OF THE AGENDA TODAY WHAT THAT
MEANS WE'RE MOVING ON TO SB
FIVE FIFTY. SUNDERED ALWAYS
BILL I THOUGHT I SAW HIM HERE
AND HE IS HERE- SOONER YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PRESENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
HAVE WITH THE BILL UP TODAY SB
FIVE FIFTY THE EMPLOYEE
PROTECTION. THE BILL FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE EMPLOYEES JEOPARDY
SB FIVE FIFTY WILL PROVIDE
EQUAL PROTECTIONS TO THE
EMPLOYMENT- EAST OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT THEY ARE
REQUIRED THE SAME PLAZA
REQUIRED TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR
CURRENTLY THE PASSES THOUSANDS
OF LAWS. THAT DICTATE EMPLOYEE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND HUNDREDS
OF REGULATIONS EACH YEAR ON
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CONVENE
EXEMPTED THEMSELVES. FROM SOME
OF THESE BURDENSOME LAWS. IF
THE LAW IS GOOD ENOUGH FOR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYEES IT
SHOULD APPLY TO OUR STAFF AS
WELL LET ME GIVE YOU A FEW
EXAMPLES. OPPOSITION SIXTY FIVE
WHICH REQUIRES CHEMICALS AND
HIGH FREQUENCIES OF LAWSUITS
AGAINST BUSINESSES THERE'S FOR
MALAHIDE IN THIS BUILDING. IN
OUR OFFICES FURNITURE THAT CAN
CAUSE CANCER OR BIRTH DEFECTS.
FLAME RETARDANTS THAT CAUSE
CANCER OR BIRTH DEFECTS LEAD
FROM BRASS OBJECTS THAT CAN
CAUSE CANCER BIRTH DEFECTS.
WAGING OUR OR OUR EMPLOYEES
DON'T GET PAID OVERTIME-
ALTERNATE WORK SCHEDULES MEAL
AND REST PERIODS WHICH ARE
OFTEN ABUSED- FOR EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE PAGA LAWSUITS. EVERY
DAY THE LEGISLATURE CAN WE TALK
ABOUT. EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS AND
THE PRIVATE SECTOR WHILE WE
DON'T LIVE UP TO THOSE
STANDARDS OURSELVES. I'M
EMPLOYERS SO I KNOW THE VALUE
OF THESE PROTECTIONS. AND I
KNOW THE COST OF THEM IT TO
COMPLY WITH THEM. EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL BUT SHOULD BECOME MORE
FAMILIAR WITH THE LAWS THEY'RE
PASSING A TO CALIFORNIA'S BY
APPLYING THEM IN THEIR- TO
THEIR OWN EMPLOYEES. I CAN THIS
CHANGE THE RIGHT THING TO DO AS
AS WELL. IT WILL END THE DOUBLE
STANDARD OF EMPLOYEE
PROTECTIONS. THAT OUR EMPLOYEES
DO NOT ENJOY- I KNOW THAT-
CENTER LAYERED THIS WAS THIS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE PRESENTED
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND-
AND- SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT I'M
DOING THIS IS A STATEMENT BILL.
AND I'M NOT THIS IS A SERIOUS-
WE WORK SOMETIMES EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN HOURS A DAY. IN THIS
CAPITAL CERTAIN TIMES OF THE
YEAR AND- NORM PLEASE DON'T GET
PAID OVERTIME. AND I IN MY OWN
BUSINESS- I PAY THAT I PAY FOR
THOSE. WHEN WE WORK LONG HOURS
IN FARMING WHICH WE DO- WE PAY
THE LAW ALLOWS NOW. HAS BEEN
SAID THAT THE- THE YOU KNOW
RULES COMMITTEE IS THERE REALLY
THERE- EMPLOYER. BUT THERE AT
WILL EMPLOYEES IN THE IN THIS
CAPITAL AND LAST YEAR I STOOD
ON THE FLOOR AND TALKED ABOUT-
WE ARE PASSING SOME- EXIT OR
SOME REGULATIONS ON THE
BUSINESS AND TALKED ABOUT- YOU
KNOW THE WITH THE WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR VERSUS THE
LEGISLATURE AND- THEN. SENATOR
CHERUB BUDGET HOLLY MITCHELL
SAID WILL THEIR SALARIED
EMPLOYEES WELL I WILL BEG TO
DIFFER THE SALARIED EMPLOYEES
ARE STILL UNDER THE- OUR
REQUIREMENTS IF NOT. EVERY
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS WOULD MAKE
THEM SALARY THAT DOESN'T APPLY
IF YOU MAKE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH. AS A SALARIED
EMPLOYEE. YOU STILL ARE
REQUIRED AS AN EMPLOYER TO NOT
ALLOW THEM TO WORK MORE THAN
FORTY HOURS A WEEK AND IF SO
YOU HAVE TO COMPENSATE THEM. SO
I JUST WANT TO BRING OUT THE
POINT THAT THIS ISN'T SOME
STATEMENT BILL I ASKED MY HIPPA
THE STAFF IF I'D HEARD FROM THE
CONSULTANT ABOUT WE KNEW
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE BILL AND-
THEIR THEIR INTERPRETATION WAS
THAT THERE. DIDN'T SEEM TO YOU
KNOW UNDERSTAND WHY WAS DOING
THE BILL SO I AM VERY COMMITTED
TO THIS BILL I THINK IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AS A
LEGISLATURE AND- AS LEGISLATORS
WE SHOULD. PRACTICE THE LAWS
THAT WE PASS AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL I DO NOT HAVE
ANY WITNESSES BECAUSE I ASKED
FOR SOME STAFF TO COME AND
TESTIFY. IT QUITE FRANKLY THEY
ARE AFRAID TO TESTIFY BECAUSE-
THEY DON'T WANNA LOSE OUR JOB.
THAT'S HOW SERIOUS THIS IS SO
MEMBERS- I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE PLEASE. THANK SENATOR DOLE-
WE'RE GOING TO- MOVED TO THE
COMMITTEE GIVEN THERE ARE NO
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES AGAIN
WE'RE GONNA TAKE OF THE SUPPORT
SIDE. OF THE BILL RIGHT NOW
DOES ANYONE HEARING COMMITTEE
WISH TO SPEAK ON THE BILL. A
NOT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM I
WILL TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM
APPEARS TO BE NO ONE PRESENT
THERE TO SPEAK. SB FIVE FIFTY-
WE WILL ESTO CONFERENCE
OPERATOR WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIFTEEN OF
SO PLEASE LET US KNOW. THIS
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
OF. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
YOU MAY PROCEED. OKAY THANK YOU
BYE MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
OPPOSITION THE SIDE OF THE BILL
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AGAIN TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ANYONE HERE. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SEEN NONE I WILL NOTE THAT
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE OVAL ROOM
OF WISHING TO SPEAK BACK TO THE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION. OF WITNESSES- WHO
ARE AVAILABLE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB FIVE FIFTY. THANK
YOU TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME I'D- THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATOR ON THE
PRINCIPLE. TO THE COMMITTEE
ITSELF AND A LOOK TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON A VERY HEAVY FOR
ME MAKE A GENERAL COMMENT ON
SENATOR DOLE YET THEIR PRE
SHEET. A YOUR EFFORTS- WITH
REGARD TO DRAWING ATTENTION TO
THIS ISSUE UP I'M NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR ROUTES TO WOULD DETAIL
THE BILL MY TAKE ON AT SOME
POINT- GIVEN MY OWN CONCERNS
WHICH MAY OR MAY NOT BE THE
SAME AS YOURS- HAD THE BEEN THE
SAME I MIGHT'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SERVICE YOUR YOUR READ-
OPPOSITION WITNESS MYSELF. I
MEAN YOU READ SUPPORT WITNESSES
SKEWS ME- BECAUSE I DO HAVE
CONCERNS TONIGHT IN THAT IN
THAT VEIN I APPRECIATE THE
ISSUE BEING ELEVATED- AND- I
WILL JUST SAY AT THE OUTSET ARE
MOVING TO SUPPORT THE BILL TO
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
DEVELOP IT FURTHER BUT- I'M NOT
SURE EXACTLY WHERE IT'S GOING
IN TERMS OF DETAIL ON IT I'M
SURE THERE WILL BE A CONCERN
FOR SOME FOLKS- IT'LL BE ON MY
COMMENTS TODAY I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT YOU'RE CERTAINLY.
WELCOME TO RESPOND LET ME IN
WHEN YOU CLOSE BUT LET ME BRING
IT BACK I'M NOT ASKING FOR A
RESPONSE RIGHT NOW LET ME BRING
IT BACK TO OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ANY COMMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE- CENTER NEWMAN
AND CENTER DRAWS ON. AND THEY
WILL COME TO CENTER WHERE HE
HAD THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ANSWERED I DO APPRECIATE. NOT
JUST WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THE ISSUE. YOU'RE BRINGING
TO OUR ATTENTION. MY ANALYSIS-
CAN. WILL THAT SORT OF. THE
FROM THE CA INTEREST THEY WERE
THEY WERE PROP. HAVE TO BE
CONSTANT. PROVISIONS ADOPTED
FOR THIS BILL THE SUCCESS TO
BECOME LAW AND SO THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION SO. WOULD YOU MIND
SPEAKING OF ISSUE CANCER THE
FULLER UNDERSTANDINGS AND MAKE
MY PHONE. WELL I'M NOT A I'M
NOT TO FAMILIAR WITH THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE
LEGISLATURE BEING EXEMPT FROM
LABOR LAWS WE ARE WE ARE
EXEMPTED FROM THEM BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T TAKEN ACTION TO.
INCLUDE THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WE'VE EXEMPTED THOSE EMPLOYEES
WHICH MEANS. THEY HAVE NO
RIGHTS. UNDER THE LAW SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF WE DON'T PAY THEM
OVERTIME WHEN THEY WORKED
TWELVE HOUR DAY. WITH THEY HAVE
NO RIGHT TO COME TO THE
LEGISLATORS I HATE DEMAND JUST
LIKE IT MY EMPLOYEES OF MY
BUSINESS WOULD GO TO THE LABOR
BOARD. AND SAY HEY MY EMPLOYER
DID NOT. I WORK THESE HOURS AND
THEY DIDN'T PAY ME AND THEN THE
LABOR WARD WOULD COME AFTER ME
THE LABOR BOARD DOESN'T COME
OUT TO THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
THEY DON'T ABIDE BY THE LAW
BECAUSE THEY'VE EXEMPTED
THEMSELVES FROM THE XACT LAWS
THAT THEY PASSED. SO I'M NOT.
FOR MIGLIOR WITH. ANY
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THAT'S NOT
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION BUT I
WOULD. BUT I WOULD LOVE TO LOOK
INTO IT IF THAT'S THE CASE AND
MAYBE WE NEED TO PUT ON THE
BALLOT. M. OKAY SO I GUESS
THAT'S- HI STEVE MY QUESTION
REMAINS UNANSWERED I
APPRECIATE. THE SENTIMENTS OF
THE WILL MOVE ON THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER
NEWMAN- DESCENDED ROSY WERE
NEXT AND THEN CENTER ALERT.
THANK YOU AND I- THANK TO
APPRECIATE RAISING THE ISSUE OF
WHAT THE STAFF- I- I DON'T HAVE
A COMPLETE THEN I WOULD NEED A
COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE DIFFERENCES ARE BETWEEN.
WHAT IS BEING PROVIDED
CURRENTLY. BY THE STATE TO OUR
OUR OUR STAFF AND WHAT. THEY'RE
LACKING- AS FAR AS EITHER RIGHT
OR- BENEFITS OR HOURLY. I DON'T
THINK THE I THINK THE IT THE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU GAVE US OVER
TIME THAT'S REALLY BASED ON
MINIMUM WAGE SO- IT'S- KIND OF
EASY FOR MOST EMPLOYEES FOR
MOST OF. THE SAY THAT THEY'RE
GETTING PAID OVERTIME BUT IT'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE I THINK OF
WHAT'S NEEDED MORE CLARITY IS
NEEDED- AND I JUST DON'T KNOW
OBVIOUSLY MINIMUM WAGE FOR MOST
IF NOT YOU KNOW OVERWHELMINGLY.
MINIMUM WAGE IS LESS AN ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE COVERED
BY HE STATE- I PREFER. OF
SURPRISE SURPRISE AB NINE SIX
NINE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ'S BILL OF WHICH I'M A
CO AUTHOR OF WHICH SAYS. I WILL
BE EXTENDED- ON A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS SO THAT THEY
CAN DECIDE ALONG WITH US AS THE
EMPLOYER WHAT'S MISSING WHAT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED WHAT NEEDS TO
BE CHANGED- SO- YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT'S THE BEST WAY
THAT'S BEEN. IN MY OPINION THE
BEST WAY OF DEALING WITH
ANYBODY'S ALL WORKING
CONDITIONS IS LEFT EMPLOYEES
AND THE EMPLOYER DECIDE WHERE
AND WHAT AND HOW MUCH IT
BECAUSE THAT WHAT'S NEEDED AND
WHAT'S NOT NEEDED. THANK YOU.
PLEASE ROSE. WELL I WAS GONNA
SAY THE CENTER INVALID TOOK ALL
THE FUN OUT OF THIS. WITH HIS
PRESENTATION I WAS GOING TO ASK
HIM AS A LEAD QUESTION HOW MANY
TIMES HE'D BEEN IN FRONT OF THE
LABOR COMMITTEE IN EIGHT YEARS
AND HE DID VOLUNTEER THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME. I WAS GOING
TO ANNOUNCE THIS YEAR'S ANNUAL
MAY DAY PICNIC AT THE DALI
RANCH UP IN THE PAPER. I THINK
THAT STILL MIGHT BE ON. A IN A
IT IS THE REAL THING IS I'M
SYMPATHETIC TO THE COMMENTS
THAT THE CHAIR AND SENATOR
DURAZO SAID AND I'M GOING TO
FOR THIS BILL AND GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO WORK ON IT BUT IT'S
CLEAR THAT CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
OUT POINT AND THEIR CONCERNS.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CONSIDERING MOVING TO FILL.
OTHERS NUMBER TWO. YES I WANNA
THANK US SENATOR DOLLY FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE FORWARD I
THINK THIS IS WHERE- I ADMIRE
THE FACT THAT WHEN. LEADERS
TAKE INITIATIVE OR IN THIS CASE
THE ELECTED- OR ANY BUSINESS
OWNER TAKES INITIATIVE AND
MAKING SURE THAT AND PROVIDING
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT IS-
OPTIMAL. OUT FOR THE EMPLOYEES
AND REALLY PUTS FORWARD THE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT IT'S THAT IT'S A
RELATIONSHIP RIGHT WE HAVE THE
EMPLOYERS AND WE HAVE THE
EMPLOYEES AND THEY NEED EACH
OTHER IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD. IN IN AN- IN
THEIR ENDEAVOR SO- THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THAT FORWARD AND I
WILL BE HAPPY TO MOVE P. THE
THIS BILL FORD. WHEN THE TIME
COMES. OKAY THE TIME SHOULD BE
COMING VERY SHORTLY- CENTER
DOLLY- YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE%
AT THIS TIME. PERSONAL I WANT
TO. THANK THE MEMBERS AND GREAT
COMMENTS I DO I AND I
APPRECIATE- CENTER LAYERED HE'S
IN ME A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE- IT
IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN
FROM THIS COMMITTEE BUT- AS AN
EMPLOYER I. I AGREE I HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH MY
EMPLOYEES AND IS A TWO WAY
STREET AND THERE ARE MANY LOST
MANY MANY LAWS THAT ARE
BURDENSOME LOS- AND ALL HAVE
BEEN PASSED FOR A GOOD REASON
IF YOU REALLY DIG INTO THE LAWS
AND FIND OUT THERE SOME ABUSES
ABSOLUTELY. ON ON ALL SIDES OF
LOS. BUT WHEN I CAME TO THE
CAPITAL I WAS JUST BLOWN AWAY
IN THE FACT THAT. OUR OFFICES
DON'T ABIDE BY THE LAWS THAT WE
PASS. AND YOU KNOW WE HEAR A
LOT OF SPEECHES ON THE FLOOR
ABOUT EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS AND HOW THE
GOVERNMENT. HOW THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN THAT. SO
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO WRONG
AWRY- RIGHT OR WRONG THEY
SHOULD SAY GET THAT RIGHT- AND
THERE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING TO THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF IT THAT'S
JUST WAS NEW TO MY V. BROUGHT
UP TO ME. AND I'LL SHARE THAT
IT THE MINIMUM WAGE IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE- IF YOU'RE MAKING. WE
DON'T PAY ANY OF OUR EMPLOYERS
MINIMUM WAGE WE PAY ABOVE THAT
UP SIGNIFICANTLY ABOUT THAT BUT
WE ARE STILL REQUIRED BY LAW.
TO PAY. TIME TIME AND A HALF ON
CERTAIN OUT WHEN THEY MEET
THOSE THRESHOLDS YOU PAY SO- I
KNOW THAT THERE'S VERY FEW
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT OUR MINIMUM
WAGE I DON'T KNOW. WHAT THEY'RE
I MEAN I KNOW IT'S MORE THAN
THAT. BUT DINNER THE DAY THEY
SHOULD STILL HAVE THE RIGHT TO.
YOU KNOW WE PASSED A BILL LAST
YEAR IN THE- SENATE SENATOR
JACKSON BROUGHT THE BILL
FORWARD ABOUT. IF YOU WANT TO
TAKE TO OUR LEAVE. AND YOU
COULD CONSECUTIVE THAT FOR
FIFTEEN WEEKS TWO HOURS AT A
TIME. AND THAT BILL PASSED AND
SO THOSE ARE THINGS I THINK ARE
EMPLOYEES SHOULD BE. HAVE THE
RIGHT TO AS WELL AND SO- FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK THE BILL AND- I
APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE- TO GET ME
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND MOVE
ON AND I WILL LOOK UP ALL THOSE
CONCERNS AND TRY TO GET YOU
BETTER INFORMATION- AS WE TAKE.
THIS JOURNEY THROUGH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WE CAN GO
FORWARD WITH A ROLL CALL VOTE
NO OF THE CONSULTANT WOULD DO
THAT PLEASE THANK YOU. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATOR CORTEZ. HI
AND THE COURT HAS THE AYE.
SENATOR OCHO BUG I. UNDER CHAU
BOGAN HIGH SENATOR ALSO.
SENATOR DORADO AYE SENATOR
LAYERED I SENATOR LAYERED HI
SENATOR NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
SENATOR NEWMAN AYE. MOTION
PASSES OF FIVE TWO ZERO THAT
BUILDS UP THANK YOU. THE YES
BUT I LOOKED AT THE NEXT BILL
HONOR GENDER IS SB SEVEN
HUNDRED- THAT A SENATOR
DROWSINESS BILL AND THE SENATE
RUSSELL YOU MAY STAY IN PLACE
IF YOU PREFER ON THE DAIS-
POLITICAL WITH PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE AND- YOU ARE CERTAINLY
WELCOME TO PRESENT THIS TIME.
OKAY MAKE SURE OKAY THREE.
SEVEN HUNDRED OKAY- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF A
ARE COMMITTEE- SB SEVEN HUNDRED
IS ABOUT MISCLASSIFIED PORT
DRIVERS HAVING ACCESS TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS- ALL MY LIFE AND IN MY
CAREER I HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS AND IT
BENEFITS THE FAMILIES BECAUSE A
PARENT LOSES THEIR JOB. IT'S
THE ONLY WAY THE FAMILY CN
KEEP THEIR HOME OR NOT BE BIG
THAT OR PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR STATE'S SAFETY NET. BUT
EVEN THIS ONE VERY MODEST
PROTECTION HAS BEEN DENIED TO
PORT TRUCK DRIVERS AS THE
PANDEMIC KIT. AND THE AMOUNT OF
CARGO IN THE PORTS DROPPED MANY
MANY DRIVERS FOUND THEMSELVES
OUT OF WORK WHEN THEY APPLIED
FOR BENEFITS MANY WERE DENIED
EVEN WORSE SOME OF THOSE
CLASSIFIED DRIVERS WERE DEEMED
TO BE EMPLOYERS. OF OTHER
DRIVERS MAKING THEM LIABLE FOR
UNEMPLOYED YOU WHY TAXES
INSTEAD OF. THE COMPANIES
PROFITING FROM THEIR WORK. NOW
WE KNOW THAT COMPANIES USE SOME
COMPANIES USE ELABORATE SCHEMES
TO MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
ESPECIALLY IN PORT DRAYAGE. THE
LABEL WORKERS AS SEPARATE
BUSINESSES LEASE THEM TRACKS
AND THEN TELL THEM TO FIND
OTHER DRIVERS- OTHER WORKERS TO
DRIVE OTHER SHIFTS ALL OF THIS
IS MEANT TO CREATE THE ILLUSION
OF INDEPENDENCE WHEN REALITY
THE WORKERS UNDER THE COMPLETE
CONTROL OF THE TRUCKING
COMPANY- SO I BELIEVE IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF OUR STATE
AGENCIES TO SEE BEYOND. THESE
FRAUD SCHEMES TO PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE WORKERS WERE BEING
HARMED. ON EIGHTY D. DECISIONS
AT THE VERY FIRST LEVEL ARE
DENYING BENEFITS AND THE
PROLONGED AW THE AND THEY
DELAYED ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THESE COMPANIES THAT ARE MOVING
GOODS THROUGH THE PORT HE D. D.
DECISIONS ARE BEING OVERTURNED
ON APPEAL. BUT WORKERS CANNOT
AND SHOULD NOT AWAIT THEIR VERY
SURVIVAL THE ABILITY TO KEEP A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS AND FOOD
ON THE TABLE DEPENDS ON TIMELY
ACCESS TO BENEFITS. WHEN WORK
DRIES UP SO. I THREE SEVEN
HUNDRED DIRECTS EDT TO FOLLOW
THE LAW IT DIRECTS THEM TO
COMPLY WITH TWO KEY DECISIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE APPEALS BOARD. THAT
HAVE RIGHTFULLY FOUND DRIVERS
TO BE EMPLOYEES AND THE
TRUCKING COMPANY TO BE THE
EMPLOYER WHO PAYS THE U. I.
TAXES IT'S. NOT ENOUGH TO SAY
WE VALUE YOU ESSENTIAL WERE. WE
HAVE TO SHOW THEM THAT WE- WILL
TREAT THEM THE WAY THEY
DESERVE. BOB IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
PER PORT TRUCK DRIVERS WHO
MOVE. 3240% OF THE GOODS IN
THIS COUNTRY OUGHT TO HAVE AN
AFFAIR ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS-
AND THAT COMPANIES THAT CHEAT
WORKERS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
AND THE STATE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AS WELL. I HAVE TO-
KEY WITNESSES MISTER CHAIR
JESSICA DURHAM DIRECTOR OF LANE
PORT CAMPAIGN AND JULIE GUTMAN
DICKINSON ATTORNEY UP WITH I.
B. T. FOR DIVISION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO- NOT
CERTAIN- WHICH LEAD WITNESS
WILL GO FIRST BUT- JESSICA
DURHAM OR JULIE GOODMAN
DICKINSON EITHER OF YOU MAY
BEGIN- WE'RE TRYING TO HOLD
OPPOSITION SUPPORT. WITNESSES
TO TWO MINUTES EACH. GREAT
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
YES YES IT'S A DINNER FOR
YOURSELF THOUGH. YES MY NAME I
JESSICA DURHAM AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE PORT CAMPAIGN AT LANE L.
A. ARRANGING AN ECONOMY. AND
THEN WE HEARD TWO WEEKS AGO
FROM ONE HIT A LOW AND DRIVER
AT UNIVERSAL CONTAINER
CONNECTION THE PORT TRUCKING
INDUSTRY JUST COULD NOT A CLEAN
OF CLASSIFIED DRIVERS. AND JUST
LAST WEEK WE SAW THE IMPACT ON
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN WHEN THESE
COMPANIES BREAK THE LAW AS YOU
KNOW THE DRIVER STRIKE THAT
SHUT DOWN A MAJOR PORT TERMINAL
IN LONG SHORE WORKERS WALKED
OFF THE JOB IN A HISTORIC SHOW
OF SOLIDARITY. INDEED DRIVERS
CONTINUED STANDING UP AND
SAYING THEIR RIGHTS MUST. BE
RESPECTED. AND FOR AND- HELL
CRITICAL. WERE TWENTY NET. THE
FINAL IN INCOME MCCARTY SAID
DRIVERS. MORE BECAUSE THERE.
EXPORTS ARE COSTS ON THE BACKS.
NOT ONLY IS THIS UNLAWFUL IN
MEANS THAT CARD. HI WHETHER OR
NOT THERE. HUNTING DRIVER THAN
TODAY. OFF INTO THEIR OWN
EMPLOYER. WHEN DR THEN APPLIED
CLAIMING STEPS BE YEAH JOB. HI
BEEN CLEARED FRAUDULENT PAID AT
THAT NINETY NINE YOU DIVERT THE
COUNT ANTI ETV MUCH INVESTING
PRACTICALLY. AND WHAT BETTER.
ALAIN WE HOPE MANY DRIVERS TO
THE OF THE YEARS. AND IT CAN BE
A ONE AND- EVEN IN THE BEST A
TIMES. YEAH DURING THE- WE SAW
STATE EVEN MORE DELAYS BECAUSE
EVEN EVEN FAILING TO MEET YOUR
COMPANY'S. SCHEME AND MAKING
DEATH. AFTER THE AND CO. REALLY
DO A QUESTION OF. AND IT HELPS
HAS MADE IT. IT'S SUCH A
COMPANY IT'S NOT THE WAGE WORK
WHO SHARED HIS WITH HIS. WE NOW
WE SIX SUCH APPEAL TO ALSO
DIFFERENT. ALL WHO GREW IN
FAVOR OF JACK JUST LAST WEEK WE
ANOTHER FINDING A JOB TO HAVE
THE INCLUDE TO INCOME.
UNIVERSAL'S OTHER COUNTY SIX
AND IBM TRACK. THEY ALSO HAVE
BEEN THE WORKERS IN THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE A BY THE U.
I. D. IN WHICH I THE CASE AND
THAT SB SEVEN. BECAUSE THIS
WILL GIVE EDT CLEARED WITH
FORWARD ON THE TRAIN TO FIGURE
OUT WHO THE- WE ASKED FOR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IT
IS TO. THE CONSIDER. YES SHE
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
JOE GUTMAN APART AT THE LAW LOS
BUSH GOTTLIEB AND COUNSEL TO
THE PORTISCH AND MANY CLASS
PORT DRIVE. TO BE CLEAR THE
LEGAL HAS WAY IN. IN EVERY
CALIFORNIA'S AND FEDERAL CASE
AT EVERY AGENCY FROM THE STEEL
I A. B. TO THE P. L. S. C. TO
THE DEAL WELL TO THE NRB. PORT
DRIVERS HAVE BEEN UNIFORMLY
FONG CAN BE EMPLOYEES OF THE
PORT TRUCKING COMPANY THEY WORK
FOR. NOT EMPLOYEES LL SEE THEIR
OWN PLAYER INCENTIVIZE THEM TO
OBTAIN I'M NOT EMPLOYERS OR
EMPLOYEES OF THEIR COWORKERS.
BUT CAN THEY SHARE A TRUCK. SB
SEVEN HUNDRED CREDIT. TO
PROVIDE CERTAIN INCLUDE TO ET I
KNOW WHO THE TRUE EMPLOYER IT.
TRUCKING COMPANIES ENGAGE
LIABILITY UNDER CALIFORNIA'S
COMPLEX YOU I CLOSED. TO YOU
I'D BE HAS DETERMINED THAT
EXISTING CASE LAW MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT FOR YOU I SEE
PURPOSES IN THE PAST
INSTITUTIONS WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
TODAY. THE TRUCKING COMPANY
EMPLOYS BOTH DRIVERS AND IS
LIABLE FOR TAXES AND THAT YOU
KNOW THE DRIVER WHO OWNS OR
LEASES THE TRUCKER. NOR. HIS
LLC IS AN EMPLOYER. SB HUNDRED
CRITICAL TO BRING TO EASY
AGENTS ON THE GROUND CORPS
OFTEN CONFUSED BY THE
INTERMEDIARY ENTITIES. EVEN
FIND ALL THE FACT POINT THE
TRUCKING COMPANY EMPLOYING BOTH
DRIVERS DVD THEN TURNS AROUND
AND SAYS THAT SHE FOUND THE L.
L. C. AND THE TEN NINETY NINES
OVERRIDE AND SOMEHOW IT MAKE
THE FIRST DRIVER HIS OLD
EMPLOYER. AND THE EMPLOYER OR
THE SECOND DRIVER. EDT IS NOW
GOING AFTER THESE ESSENTIAL LOW
WAGE WORKERS- PAYROLL TAX. IN A
WORDSRATHER THAN LOOK AT THE
REALITY OF THE FACTS BEFORE IT
TO ENSURE THE WORKERS WHO
SHOULD BE PROTECTED UNDER THE
LAW ARE PROTECTED. EDT IS
RELYING ON LOG AND FORMALISTIC
READING OF THE LAW. THIS IS A
MANIFEST INJUSTICE AND IS
CONTRARY TO THE VERY PURPOSE
UNDERLYING THE CALIFORNIA'S
UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM. WE URGE
YOU TO GIVE THE EDT THE CLARITY
THAT THEY SAY THEY NEED BY
SUPPORTING THIS CRITICAL BILL.
WHICH WILL REDIRECT CRITICAL
AGENCY RESOURCES AWAY FROM
PROSECUTING DRIVERS THAT DID
NOTHING WRONG TOWARD
PROSECUTING THE MULTI BILLION
DOLLAR COMPANY. RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE UNLAWFUL GAINS AND ARE
FAILING TO PAY PAYROLL TAXES.
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE
LABOR UNREST THAT WE SAW LAST
WEEK WITH THE HISTORIC SHUTDOWN
OF A MAJOR PORT TERMINAL LOS
ANGELES DURING THE PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS STRIKE. WOULD LIKELY
CONTINUE TO RISE TO NEW HEIGHTS.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE- WILL
CONTINUE WITH SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN HUNDRED BY ASKING IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD M. C. NONE I WILL
CHECK- THE OVERFLOW ROOM S. C.
KNOWING THERE TO TESTIFY WILL
GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR IN S. OF FOR ANY
SUPPORT WITNESSES- AND YOU MAY
BEGIN- QUEUING THEM UP AND
PLEASE LET US KNOW- THE NUMBER
THAT YOU HAVE IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU AND FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN HUNDRED.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
FOUR LINES INTO THIS TIME.
THANK YOU PLEASE PERSON WILL.
GO TO LINE SEVENTY EIGHT.
PARDON ME LINE. FORTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FORTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JACKIE
GRANT WHILE WITH THE FTW LAST
AND STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE WILL
EXTRA LINE THIRTY SEVEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU DON'T
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD LINE. FORTY
SIX. MISTER TEN MEMBERS KEEPING
DATA ON BEHALF OF THE TRANSPORT
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA IN
SUPPORT. LINE. THIRTY JEREMY
ARNOLD ON BEHALF OF CLUE CLERGY
AND LAITY UNITED FOR ECONOMIC
JUSTICE STRONG SUPPORT. MISTER
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN CUBA THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERYMUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION ON THE BILL
THERE'S- NO IDENTIFIED LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS- WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISH TO
SPEAK. I'M SEEN NONE I WILL
CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM AGAIN-
THERE'S NOBODY THERE WISHING TO
SPEAK. LAST COLDER I WILL COME
BACK TO THE MODERATOR IN THIS
TIME LAST COULD QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON SB
SEVEN HUNDRED- AND AGAIN.
PRESHEAF YOU LETTING US KNOW
HOW MANY THERE ARE. THANK YOU
AND IF THERE ARE ANY INVOICES
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS STAR THEN
ZERO AT. THIS TIME. PARDON ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU- THE
BRINGS IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK OR RAISE QUESTIONS- ON S.
B. SEVEN HUNDRED. YES CENTER
NEWMAN I THANK YOU MR
CHURCHILL- I FEEL LIKE THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST IN FACT THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME I'VE HAD A
BILL. AND WHEN IT WHEN I
COMMITTEES AT THAT ADDRESSES
PROBLEMS WITH THE PORRIDGE- IS
FOUR ZERO DRIVERS. IT SOMETIMES
FEELS LIKE WE'RE PLAYING A GAME
OF WHACK A MOLE WHERE WHERE THE
EMPLOYERS OR THE- THE FOLKS
WHO. HAVE THE BUSINESS- DEPLOY
ALL KINDS OF STRATAGEMS TO
REDUCE THE WAGES OF THE
WORKERS- AND OTHERWISE DEPRIVE
THEM OF PROTECTIONS AND IT'S
SORT OF IRONIC BECAUSE THE
POOREST. IT'S NOT A SMALL
BUSINESS AND IT'S NOT AN
UNPROFITABLE BUSINESS. SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL- AND
I'M GLAD TO BE A PART OF THE
BROADER SOLUTION. OF
SYSTEMICALLY ADDRESSING THIS
PROBLEM SO WE'RE NOT ALWAYS
TRYING TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN
ANY GIVEN YEAR AS A THANK YOU
TO SEND A BROWSER TO RUSSIA FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL AND IF I
COULD I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A- CO AUTHOR. MOVIE FOR. THANK
YOU CENTER NEW. OTHER COM ARE.
ON THE DAIS- THE SCENE. MEMBERS
YOUR YES. ONE SENATOR. IRAN'S I
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU. I
HAVE- HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO
THE CONCERN THAT THIS BILL
WOULD- SIR THE AJIJIC CARE TORE
A JUDY CARE TORY SORRY PROCESS
CONTEMPLATED IN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE FOR
C. Y. A. B. DECISIONS TO BECOME
PRESIDENT. WELL- MAYBE THEM-
ARE WITNESS- EXTRA WINGS COULD
ANSWER BUT I JUST WANT TO START
BY SAYING. IT WILL FIT WE'RE
NOT SKIPPING ANYTHING OR BY
PASSING ANY PROCESS THE- RIGHT
NOW WHAT'S GOING ON IS AT THE
VERY BOTTOM LEVEL THE EDT IS
DECIDING- TO DENY THESE- PORT
TRUCKERS THE U. I. BENEFITS AND
IN FACT BLAMES THEM. BUT THEN
AS THE DISEASE AS THE CASE GOES
UP IT HAS TO BE ONE BY ONE-
APPEALED AS THE CASES GO UP
THEY GET OVERTURNED ON THE
RIGHT DECISION IS MADE SO WE'RE
NOT BY PASSING ANYTHING WE WANT
TO CLARIFY AND SAY. ENOUGH
WOULD BE LAYING THE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY WITH THESE PEOPLE
WHO ALL THEY WANT IS THE
MINIMAL WAY MINIMAL ON ONE OF A
MINIMAL- BENEFITS OF OUR SAFETY
NET THEY JUST WANT TO BE ABLE
TO COLLECT SOME UNEMPLOYMENT
WHILE THEY'RE OFF OF WORK SO
WE'RE NOT BYPASS IN ANYTHING.
IT'S ESTABLISHED BY THE APPEALS
COURT ALREADY OVER AND OVER WE
JUST WANT TO SAY AT THE LOWEST
LEVEL FOR THE INITIAL DECISION
IS MADE THAT THEY SHOULD FOLLOW
THESE PARTICULAR TO COURT
DECISIONS FOLLOW THEM SO THAT
THOSE WERE THOSE BOND TRUCKERS
COULD GET THEIR. BENEFITS BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF- WITH THE- ADMIN
LAW TO ADD ANYTHING TO THAT.
THIS IS THE- SURE. SURE I THANK
YOU AS THE NEW ADDRESS A YES-
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE
IS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING HERE THE
JEWS SURFING ANY EDUCATED
TEACHER CORPS YOU COULD TRY TO
PROCESS. YOU I. A. B. HAS
ROLLED AND HAS FOUND THAT
TRUCKING COMPANIES ARE THE
EMPLOYER AND IT'S TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE CAN FIND BE
POURED INTO THE DRIVERS SHOULD
BE THE EMPLOYERS AND FORCING
IMPLICATE PAYROLL TAXES. AND WE
HAVE SUBSEQUENTLY MADE A
REQUEST WE WANT TO THE PROCESS
THAT YOU AYE A BEAT TO MAKE THE
DECISION TO PRESIDENTIAL AND
THAT IS PENDING. ON IT AND THIS
LEGISLATION AT THE SAME TIME SO
CRITICAL BECAUSE OF THE URGENCY
OF THE PREDICAMENT OF DRIVERS
WHO ARE BLOCKED THE STAFF
PAYROLL TAXES AND BEEN DENIED
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THEY
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY ALL TAXES
MEANWHILE THE XPO'S OF THE
WORLD THE CONTAINER CONNECTIONS
OF THE WORLD THE UNIVERSAL
DOESN'T COUNTY THE WORLD OVER
THE PAYROLL TAXES TO THE MUCH
NEEDED COFFERS OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND ARE
GETTING OFF SCOT FREE SO.
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IS NEEDED
THE DRIVERS ARE FRUSTRATED
STRIKE ACTIONS HAVE OCCURRED
LAST WEEK AND I AM CONFIDENT
MORE. WILL HAPPEN IF WE DON'T
ADDRESS THE ISSUE. OKAY THANK
YOU. AGAIN TO THE WITNESS FOR
AFFECT. OF HE STORE BEFORE
NUMBER. THANK YOU- MISTER CHAIR-
ANOTHER FOR YOU SO. EDUCATE ME
ON WHAT BIT IN FOR ME UNDER
BECAUSE SOME OF THE TRUCKERS I
HAVE MET WITH OUR INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND THEY WANT TO
REMAIN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS.
OUR PORT TRUCKERS. NOT
AUTONOMOUS IN THEIR IN THEIR IF
YOU MAKING AS FAR AS WORK AND
HOW LONG THEY WORK AND WHAT
THEY DO IS THERE A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN AND I'M NOT SURE THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF TRUCKERS
THAT THEY ARE BUT IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PORT
TRUCKERS AND- OTHER. TRUCKERS
WELL. I'M NOT THERE IS
DIFFERENCES I'M SURE BETWEEN
TRUCKERS OF DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES BUT HERE WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND IS A SYSTEMATIC
ABUSE OF MIS CLASSIFYING. PORT
TRUCKERS WHO ARE NOT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
THAT'S THE SCHEME FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO GET OUT OF PLAY
PAIN ALL THE THINGS. THAT I'M
AN EMPLOYER IS NORMALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR WORKERS
COMPENSATION OR- DISABILITY YOU
CAN GO ON AND ON AND ON SO AS
LONG AS THEY MISCLASSIFIED THAT
TRUCKER AS A AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR THE EMPLOYER THE
TROOP LAWYER DOESN'T HAVE TO
PROVIDE PAY FOR ALL THOSE
THINGS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT'S BECOME SUCH
A- ON INDUSTRY SCHEME FAR MORE
THAN OTHER INDUSTRIES THEY'VE
MADE THAT THE MODEL- I HAVE
SOME NOTES ABOUT THEIR FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LABOR
COMMISSIONER DECISIONS. WITH
OVER FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN UNPAID WAGES AND
DAMAGES THESE ARE DECISIONS
THAT WERE MADE BY OUR STATE
AGENCIES SAYING THERE IS ON THE
BEAUCE HERE. BY MISS
CLASSIFYING THESE PORT TRUCKERS
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS I'M
SURE THERE MAY BE SOME FALL
WITHIN OF THE PORT TRUCKERS
THAT ARE TRULY MEET THE TEST OF
WHAT IS AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR BUT IN THIS CASE
THEY ARE OVERWHELMINGLY
EMPLOYEES THEY'RE NOT
OVERWHELMINGLY. INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND IT'S JUST A
SCHEME. WITH THIS BILL. A FOR
AT ALL THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WHO WISH TO BE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AS PORT
TRUCKERS IF IT THIS IS THESE
ARE PORT TRUCKERS WHO TAKE
THEIR CLAIMS BECAUSE THEY SAY
THEY'RE NOT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. SO IF THEY ARE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO FILE A
COMPLAINT YOU KNOW THIS IS
THOSE UP BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO SAY IS IT FACTUALLY THE
COMPLAINT IS MADE AND THE
INFORMATION IS GIVEN. ODD TO-
JUSTIFIED MISS CLASSIFICATION
THEN WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE
COURT'S DECISIONS AND QUIT
MAKING EVERYBODY GOAL ONE BY
ONE OF THE APPEALS COURT. SO
YOU DON'T THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EACH
INDEPENDENT AT PORT TRUCKER IN
ORDER TO OR WHEN TEY MAKE THE
CLAIMS. FOR EDT. YEAH OF YES
THEY THEY CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS. IF
YOU'RE IN THE IF YOU'RE TRULY
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AND
YOU DON'T FILE A COMPLAINT
THAT'S NOT OUR CONCERN. MY
CONCERN IS THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH ARE SAYING THEY ARE
MISCLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS THEY AREN'T MISSED-
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS THEY
ARE IN FACT EMPLOYEES. AND
ULTIMATELY AFTER THEY GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE LITIGATION
PROCESS THE DECISION IS THAT
YES THEY ARE EMPLOYEES THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN GRANTED. THE
U. Y. BENEFITS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU ANYTHING ANYTHING
ELSE FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. A C. NINE NINE
COMPACT USER GROWTH OF HER
CLOTHES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO PURGE ON BEHALF
OF ALL OF THOSE MISCLASSIFIED
PORT TRUCKERS UNDERAGE AND I
BOTH THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO FOR ALL YOUR GOOD
WORK IN THIS AREA AND- THANK
YOU. THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
ALMOST CALL THE ROLL CALL
WITHOUT THE MOTION. SIR IF.
DIFFERENT TURN OF EVENTS-
CENTER WEIRD MOVE THE BILL AND-
I'LL ASK FOR THE- SECOND WOULD
HAVE DIED FOR LACK OF A MOTION.
SORRY COLLUSION IS. TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR COURTESY HI. SENATOR
CORTEZ III CENTER- CHAU BOKE
HI. SENATOR CHAU BOCA HI
SENATOR TORONTO. SENATOR ALSO
AVE SENATOR LAYERED. AND LAYARD
AVE SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR
NEWMAN AYE. IDENTIFIER THE
QUOTE WAS A FIVE TWO ZERO VOTE
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL ITSELF.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON NOW
URBANIST TO BILLS WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR LIEBERMAN
SEE THAT SHE'S HERE WELCOME
CENTRAL ASIA AND UNDERSTAND TO
BE PRESENT ON S. B. FOURTEEN.
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ONE SECOND WHILE I GET MY
NOTES. ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. TODAY I PRESENT
AS BEFORE TEN TO ENSURE THAT
WORKER SAFETY IS NEVER DELAYED
OR CERTIFIED AS A RESULT OF
DUPLICATIVE EXPENSIVE AND
UNNECESSARY ANALYSIS. IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED INTO LAW SB SIX
SEVENTEEN WHICH REQUIRES STATE
AGENCIES TO PREPARE AN IN DEPTH
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENT OF ANY
REGULATION WITH AN ESTIMATED
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF OVER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC ASSESSMENT IS CALLED
THE STANDARDIZED REGULATORY
IMPACT ASSESSMENT ALSO KNOWN AS
THE SHARIA. WHEN IT COMES TO
WORKER SAFETY AND HEALTH
REFORMS WE'RE ALL ALREADY AWARE
OF THE EXTENSIVE PRACTICES THAT
FINALIZED THOSE STEPS INCLUDE.
OFTEN A BILL SIGNED INTO LAW
DIRECTING CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS BOARD. O. S. H. B. TO
TAKE ACTION ON A PARTICULAR
ISSUE MULTIPLE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE HEARINGS
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT
WHICH WILL FURTHER ACCESS TO
FIGHT FISCAL IMPACT. THE O. S.
H. S. B. THEM EXTENSIVELY
REVIEWS THE COSTS AND BENEFITS
OF ANY STANDARD. BY THIS POINT
AT LEAST FOR FEDERAL FISCAL
ANALYSES HAVE BEEN DONE AND
HAVE OCCURRED FOR THE RULE
MAKING PROCESS TO BE COMPLETED.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE SHRIYA
REVIEWS REVIEW MANDATE A FIFTH
PHYSICAL FISCAL ANALYSIS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS ALREADY THOROUGH
PROCESS. THREE CAN EXTEND THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS BY ONE TO
TWO YEARS OR EVEN MORE IN TURN
TO CONTINUE TO ENDANGER THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS IN THE
WORKPLACE. A FURTHER DELAY IN
ADOPTING SAFETY MATT STANDARDS
HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
AND I'VE ALREADY GONE THROUGH
MULTIPLE LOWER LEVELS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW. MAY
PLACE WORKERS AT AN INCREASED
RISK OF SERIOUS INJURY OR DEATH.
POSIBLES BUT DO REQUIRE. SUCH
AS INDOOR HEAT THE STANDARD
REQUIRED BY SB ELEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. HAVE
SUFFERED SEVERE TO SEVERE
DELAYS AS WE WILL RESULT OF
THIS PROCESS. MANY WORKERS ARE
STILL IN JEOPARDY ON THE JOB.
THE LANGUAGE FOR THE INDOOR
HEAT STANDARD HAS YET TO EVEN
BE PRESENTED TO THE O. S. H. S.
B. DESPITE LEGISLATION
REQUIRING THIS TO HAPPEN OVER
TWO YEARS AGO. THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO ADDITIONAL
YEARS THUS FAR THE INDOOR
WORKERS HAVE LABORED IN
GRUELING HEAT WITH NO CLEAR HE
PROTECTION UNDER THE LAW. FOR
THE PANDEMIC IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
SOME OF THIS DELAY IN JANUARY
TWO ONE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THE DEADLINE WAS ALREADY LONG
GONE WHEN CODE APPEARED OVER
ONE YEAR LATER. ALSO IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS TO SIGNIFICANT
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS WERE
APPROVED AND A SIX A SEVEN
MONTH PROP- PROCESS ONE
PROTECTING WORKERS FROM
WILDFIRE SMOKE AND ANOTHER FROM
COVERED NINETEEN. AS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS THESE DID NOT
REQUIRE SHARIA BUT THE
REGULATIONS TO RECEIVED
THOROUGH VETTING WITH PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AGENCIES TO
ANALYZE AND STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK. THESE AND OTHER
EXPERIENCES HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
SRI BRINGS LITTLE TO THE WORKER
SAFETY RULE MAKING PROCESS
OTHER THAN GREATER DELAYS
INFLATED STATE COSTS WITH MORE
INJURIES ILLNESSES AND
FATALITIES. I WOULD ARGUE THAT
SHARIA CAN MAKE WORKERS LESS
SAFE. AS SUCH AS BEFORE TEN
EXEMPTS CAL OSHA FROM THE
REQUIREMENT TO PERFORM SHRIYA
ON ANY PROPOSED MAJOR
REGULATION WITH A PROJECTED
FISCAL IMPACT OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. ALL OTHER EXISTING
LAYERS OF REVIEW INCLUDING
INTERNAL FISCAL ANALYSIS THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE PROCESS THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS FOR PUBLIC HEARINGS
AND MEETINGS AND THE FEDERAL
MAKING PROCESS WOULD REMAIN IN
PLACE. THIS BILL REFLECTS THE
EXCEPTIONALLY DETAILED FISCAL
ANALYSIS THAT ALREADY OCCURS AT
CAL OSHA AND ALLOWS THE AGENCY
TO FOCUS SCARCE RESOURCES AND
MORE EFFECTIVE WAYS. MOST
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL WOULD
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF WORKERS. A PATH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WITH BEEN SUPPORTED
IS MUCH SNIDER OF THE LABOR
FEDERATION WHEN APPROPRIATE
MEMBERS I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR A LEYVA. NOW
WE WILL MOVE ON TO YOUR WE HAVE. MITCH TIGER
AND JUST ONE I CAN DISTRICT
COURT DISMISSED- IS MUCH
STRONGER ON THE LINE. A PLANT.
PLEASE PRESS FOR YOU- SURE.
SURE MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL THAT
IS. ARE ABOUT MAKING GOVERNMENT
WORK BETTER AND PROPHETICALLY
IN THE CASE ALLOWING THIS ONE
AGENCY TO WORK FASTER AND AT
LESS COST WHILE IN NO WAY
LIMITING THE ABILITY OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO WEIGH IN ON THE
PROCESS. AND THAT IS CALLOSUM
ABOUT ALLOWING THESE
REGULATIONS TO GET IN PLACE
FASTER IN A WAY THAT WILL
PREVENT INJURIES AND ILLNESSES
AND ABSOLUTELY SAVE LIVES.
UNDER LABEL REALLY COVERED ALL
THE MAIN POINTS BUT WE WOULD
REALLY FOCUS ON THAT EXAMPLE OF
INDOOR HEAT AS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS BILL MAKES
SO MUCH SENSE. WHEN THE BUILDER
FELLOWSHIP AND THE STANDARDS
BOARD TO ADOPT AN INDOOR HEAT
REGULATION WAS APPROVED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. HELLO JUST
STARTED THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
PROCESS QUICKLY AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND I HAD. SEVERAL OF
THESE MEETINGS TO IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE WAS NO
LIMIT WHATSOEVER ON THE ABILITY
OF STAKEHOLDERS TO WAY AND-
THERE ARE NO TIME LIMITS YOU
COULD. TURN IN A LETTER THAT
WAS AS LONG AS YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WHATEVER KIND OF COST
IMPACT THAT ANYONE WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT AND HE DID WE GOT.
VERY DETAILED IN THE ALL SORTS
OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE COST OF
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MONITORS THE
CONSTANT DIFFERENT TYPES OF
TRAINING. AND ALL THOSE ISSUES
WERE COVERED VERY THOROUGHLY.
AND THEN FOLLOWING THAT THERE
ARE MULTIPLE VERSIONS OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT WERE PROPOSED. BY
MY COUNT EIGHT DIFFERENT
VERSIONS THAT WERE FLOATED OUT
THERE EACH WITH. UP TIME FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO WEIGH IN ON
AFTER THE FACT AND- I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS IS HOW ALL OTHER
AGENCIES DO IT BUT WITH
CALLOSUM. ANYONE OF THESE MAJOR
REGULATIONS ALWAYS HAS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THE TOUCH TO IT
UNLESS IT'S AN EMERGENCY
REGULATION. AND ALSO ALL THAT
PRODUCE LANGUAGE THAT'S BEEN
FINALIZED IN APRIL OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND THEN IT'S JUST
BEEN SITTING THERE. AND THEN
WORKERS HAVE BEEN WAITING AND
SUFFERING THROUGH THE HAZARD
FOR TWO YEARS. BUT NO SOLUTION
WELL THE SOLUTION IS COMPLETED
BUT WE ALL HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
CONSULTANT TO COMPLETE A PEDIA.
AND SINCE THEN JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN. THERE HAVE
BEEN AT LEAST SIXTY SIX ZERO
INDOOR HEAT RELATED COMPLAINT.
AND THAT'S WITHOUT A STANDARD
AND QUITE. SO IN MOST CASES THE
EMPLOYER WAS PROBABLY NOT
TECHNICALLY DOING ANYTHING
ILLEGAL YET. BUT THE WORKERS
WERE IN SUCH BAD SHAPE. WHEN I
HADN'T ACCEPTED THE RISK OF
RETALIATION. AND CALLED
CALIBRATION ANYWAY. AND YOU
KNOW WE ALWAYS THAT THREE ARE
WITH. THEY'RE VERY INTEREST.
VERY HELPFUL DOC. BY WHAT THEIR
VALUE IS. ARE YOU IN THE WE
BELIEVE LAST THE VALUE OF A
WERE LIFE. AND MAKE THE MISTAKE
THAT THE THAT. THIS IS WERE
MADE WHEN WE ARE SOME LIKE THAT
TO DELAY OR SAFETY RIGHT BY ONE
TO TWO YEARS WE'RE SAYING THAT
THE CULPABLE. OF WORKERS TO GET
HURT BUT WORKERS TO DIE WHILE
WE WAIT FOR THIS DOCUMENT TO BE
PREPARED. WE THINK THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE WE THINK THAT THIS
BILL OFFERS A VERY SIMPLE
SOLUTION THAT WILL SAVE MONEY
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE
FUNCTIONING OF GOVERNMENT AT
ALL ABSOLUTELY SAVE WORKERS.
LIVES WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK VERY MUCH. THAT
IS BRIDGE TIGER IN LEAD SUPPORT.
SB FOUR TEN WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE DO WE HAVE.
SIR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GIVE ANY
OTHER. SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE
IN THIS ROOM CENA DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEN NONE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
A SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TEN WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOUR- IF
YOU'RE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
S. BEFORE TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH I MEAN VERY
LITTLE IF YOU HAVE TO W.
WESTERN STATE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT PLEASE AND WE WILL
MOVE ON. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
FORTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAITLIN
DATA ON BEHALF OF THE LA COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU HAVE ONE
MORE IN Q. OVER PROVIDING THEIR
LINE NUMBER WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY EIGHT ONE MOMENT. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRED MEMBERS CHRIS TOP MAYOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN. YOU CORTES THANK YOU.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU MATTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD HE HEARD
FROM ALL THE YEAH. WITH THIS IS
A SUPPORT. THIRTY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN MADAM CHAIR THERE ARE NO
QUICK NO- LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FOM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE ONE
LEAD UP. THREE THIRTY. AND WE
DO HAVE ONE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS THAT IS MISTER ROBERT
NO TREE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE MISTER MO
TREAT- ARE YOU ON THE LINE- YES
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED SIR- THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROBERT MACHINE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ALONG WITH THE COALITION
ARE OPPOSED BEFORE CAN- I WANT
TO JUST CLARIFY THE ISSUE UP
FRONT. WHO RECOGNIZED THE
CONCERNS I'M THAT ANALYSIS AND
TRANSPARENCY IN GOVERNMENT
MEASURES ALWAYS TAKE TIME THE
REPEATED HEARING OF LEGISLATION
SUCH AS THE DRAFTING IT OUT BY
STAFF. ALL OF THOSE STEPS TAKE
TIME THEY SLOW DOWN LEGISLATION
JUST LIKE REGULATIONS BUT WE
SEE THOSE UNHEALTHY AND THAT
THAT PROCESS AND VALUABLE
BECAUSE THE RESULT IN BETTER
POLICY. I WOULD BE THE SAME
WITH THE SERIE A PROCESS- I'D
LIKE TO GET THAT THE TWO I
THINK THE BIG ISSUES HERE RIGHT
I THAT FIRST THE VALUE OF THE
THREE OF PROCESS- FOR BRIEF
CONTACT- THOROUGHLY THE
ACCURATE NUMBER I THREE AT-
BASIC PREMISE MORE IN DEPTH
ANALYSIS FOR REGULATIONS THAT
IMPACT OVER FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS- I DO WHICH IS WHY DID
WAS CREATE RECENTLY UNDER AT.
SIX SEVENTEEN I THOUGHT OUR
CALDERON THAT- AND ONE MEASURE
OF WHETHER OR NOT IT'S A FACT
IT- WE CAN LOOK AT THAT IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE L. A- THE
OFFICE. PUT OUT A REVIEW OF THE
JURY A PROCESS AND COMMENTED
AND I'M QUOTING WE FIND SOME OF
THE CHANGES HERE HAVE LED TO
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE QUALITY AND
CONSISTENCY OF. AGENCIES
ANALYSIS OF MAJOR REGULATION.
BY YOU THE L. A. R. THANK THE
THREE OF THAT HAVE. PROVED THE
THAT. AND TO THE TO THE POINT
MADE BY THE PROPONENT IS BIT
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS. CAN IN OTHER
PRETTY GOOD THING OUT.
UNANSWERED STAFF NOW NOTE THE
POINT THE ONE ASSEMBLY. IS THAT.
BUT APART OF FINANCE HAS TO
REVIEW. AND COMMENT ON SURREY
ANALYSES TO IDENTIFY IT THE
METHODOLOGY THE CALCULATIONS
ARE ESSENTIALLY. CORRECT IF
THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY TO
CALCULATE WHAT IT'S GONNA DO
THE TO THE ECONOMY WHAT'S GONNA
CHANGE WILL COST. AND IF YOU
LOOK AT U. S. WEBSITE YOU CAN
VIEW THE OTHER DELAY IN MANY
CASES WILL PUSH BACK AND SAY NO
AGENTS YOU'VE DONE THIS MATH
ROCK. NO CHANGE THERE SO TO THE
IDEA THAT WITHOUT THE PRODUCT
THAT WE WOULD HAVE THE SAME
DATA JUST AS WELL I THINK THAT
IT'S- IT'S PROVEN. BY DLF
WEIGHING IN ON REGULATIONS.
THAT HAVING TO CHANGE THE
CALCULATION- ALL IT IS EXAMPLE-
WE TALK THREE THE THING OUT
THERE AND- L. Y. THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT STATEMENT WHICH IS
LITERALLY A FIVE PAGE. CHECK
THE BOX FORM WHICH AGENCIES ARE
REQUIRED TO DO WITH YOU IF YOU
GET RESTORING AS ALTERNATIVE.
THAT DID NOT COME ANYWHERE NEAR
THE DEPTH OF SERBIAN AL PACINO-
YOU KNOW COULD BE A HUNDRED
PAGES. OF AND GO TO INDUSTRY TO
INDUSTRY CALCULATION.
CALCULATION ARE YOU KNOW THE
LEVEL OF DETAIL IS JUST NOT
CAPTURED OTHER PLACES SO WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT VALUE. IT'S.
CERTAINLY DIFFERENT IF YOU LOOK
AT THE DOCUMENTS- THE LAST THE
TOUCH ID LIKE TO ME- I THINK MR
STEIGER MENTIONED IT SHOULD THE
ISSUE OF HELLO SHOULD THREE AT
THE TYPICALLY GOING SLOW
WAITING ON A CONSOLE TO BE
PRECISE ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
HAVE TAKEN SOME TIME IT BECAUSE
OF THE SPECIFIC OUTSIDE
CONSULTING COMPANY CALLUSES
CHOSEN TO CONTRACT WITH AND
THEIR WORKLOAD. BUT THAT IS NOT
A PROBLEM WITH SHARIA OR THE
VALUE OF SERBIA ECONOMICALLY-
INDEED THAT IS A CONSTANT ISSUE
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
CONSULTANT THE CALLOUS HAS
CONTRACTED WITH AND I THINK
THAT THAT KIND OF ISSUE WHICH
IS NOT A PROBLEM NOW THIS IS A
VALUE BUT IT DOES HAVE A
CONTRACTING ISSUE- INTAKE BACK
ISN'T A REASON TO THROW OUT
THIS VALUABLE ECONOMIC TOOL AND
INDEED I THINK THAT THEY AT AT
MISTER SPEAKER NOTED IT IS A
VALUABLE ECONOMIC IT OUT THESE
OTHERWISE THE BILL WOULD BE
GETTING RID OF IT FOR ALL
AGENCIES THAT DOESN'T DO THAT
RIGHT ONLY BECAUSE THE FOR CAL
OSHA. I THINK THAT IN ITSELF
ALSO UNDERLINED THE VALUE THREE
SO WHILE WE ARE WHAT WE AGREED
IT DELAYED BEEN DEREGULATION
THEY'RE NOT IDEAL BUT WE THINK
THE VALUE OF SHARIA
INSIGNIFICANT AND DINNER. HE
MAINTAINED A CALLOUS. EVEN AS
WE ARE. AT THE TAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS. LET'S
MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES AND UP
OF AS- FOR TEN. IN ROOM FOR
FORTY TWO OR THREE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
OPPOSITION. TWO THREE FOUR TEN
SEE NONE ARE THERE ANY WITH-THIS IS A ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION SB TEN. SEEN NONE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
IDEA THAT IT TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB PORTENT WILL BEGIN. MADAM
CHAIR WILL GO TO ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMAN BIRTH CATHOLICATE OFF
ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT OFTEN ENOUGH PRESENT
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THE JUNIOR HOWEVER. YEAH
NEXT WEEK WE'LL GO TO ONE FIFTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WE ARE
HEARING RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. WHAT THIS MONTH IS
IN MEXICO THE LINE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LADY
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
CONNECT WITH THE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE SIX TWO TWO IS
TAKING THE LINE OUT OF Q. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE HAVE TWO MORE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE THE
PROVIDER LINE NUMBERS TO THEM.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY FOUR GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS RYAN
PEOPLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO S.
B. FOR TEN. WE'LL GO NEXT TO
LINE SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE.
SURE MEMBERS OF DEALING GIBBONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ONE
MOMENT FOR OUR NEXT- CALLER. WE
HAVE NO IN HOUSE INTO THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CHECK WITH THE
LINES ONE MORE TIME TO MAKE
SURE WE WERE ABLE TO HEAR FROM
ALL THE- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOR TEN.
THANK YOU LITERACY- THE LINES
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BOETTICHER WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS DO WE ADD TO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. HONESTLY FOR TEN.
THE CENTER LEVEL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR I WOULD JUST SAY TO THE
CHAMBER THAT CAL OSHA IS ABOUT
WORKER SAFETY AND CAL OSHA HAS
PROVEN AS WAS NOTED THAT THEY
CAN ACTUALLY THEY'RE ACTUALLY
CAPABLE OF TURNING AROUND
REGULATIONS THAT PROTECT THE
HEALTH WELFARE WORKERS VERY
QUICKLY AS THEY DID WITH THE
WILDFIRES AND COVERED NINETEEN
THIS IS BILL IS JUST ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN WORKERS
ARE IN AN UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT
AND A LAW HAS BEEN PASSED THE
REGULATIONS CAN BE PROMULGATED
IN A TIMELY MANNER MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA. DO WE HAVE A MOTION AS
BEFORE TEN- MOVED. THANK YOU
THE MOTION HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR TO RAZA. CONSULTANT
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ HE- HI SENATOR
CORTEZ THE AYE SENATOR O. JOGO
NO. SENATOR CHAU BOGUE NO
SENATOR BRONSON. SENATOR ALSO
BY SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
LAYERED HI SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN I. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE BILL IS OUT I
BELIEVE. FOR FORTY ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THE BILL IS OUT
AND IT DOES PASS THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA TODAY FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION VENIPUNCTURE THANK
YOU MEMBERS. SAN RIVER- YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH- SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHAIR FOR FOUR THANK YOU FOR
TAKING SO MUCH TIME WITH MYSELF
ON THIS BILL AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I WILL BE
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TODAY WHICH I WILL SPEAK TO IN
JUST ONE MOMENT BUT I JUST WANT
TO ALSO SAY THAT DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS- WE HAVE WE
RECOGNIZE WE HAVE MORE WILL
WORK TO DO ON THIS BILL. AND WE
WILL BE TAKING IT WILL BE
WORKING ON THAT AS THE PROCESS
MOVES FORWARD WE DID NOT HAVE
TIME TO GET EVERYTHING FROM ALL
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS BUT THE
MOMENT THAT I AM TAKING TODAY-
REMOVED JOINT LIABILITY AND
PENALTIES FOR FAILURE TO MAKE
YOU I. TRUST FROM PAYMENTS AND
CARRY WORKERS COMPENSATION
REQUIRE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
AND THIRD PARTIES TO PROVIDE A
THIRTY DAY NOTICE OF A
VIOLATION TO THE DIRECT
CONTRACTOR AND SUBCONTRACTOR
ALLOWING THEM TO CURE THE
VIOLATION DURING THAT PERIOD.
ALSO TO REQUIRE THAT NOTICE BE
FILED WITH THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD WHICH WILL
TRACK THE WAGE THAT VIOLATION
ON THE ORIGINAL EMPLOYERS
LICENSE AND JOINT LIABILITY FOR
WAGE VIOLATION PENALTIES MAY
APPLY IF THREE NOTICES ARE
FILED. WITH THE C. L. C. S.
WILL BE WITHIN A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. WITHOUT SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN AIMS TO PREVENT WAGE
THEFT WITHIN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY I WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE SEEKING TO GO AFTER
THE BAD ACTORS IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND TO HELP THOSE THAT PLAY BY
THE RULES AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR WORKERS ARE PAID ON TIME.
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY BUILT OUR WORLD CAT
CLASS INFRASTRUCTURE IS A KEY
DRIVER OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY
AND PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOUSING UNITS
ANNUALLY TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF A GROWING CALIFORNIA
POPULATION. DUE TO THE SKILLS
REQUIRED AND THE FAIR WAGES AND
BENEFITS WORKERS RECEIVED THE
INDUSTRY PROVIDED A PATHWAY TO
THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WHO COULD THEN AFFORD
TO PURCHASE THE HOME. THAT THEY
BUILT. UNFORTUNATELY FOR MORE
FORTY. THOSE HAVE BEEN GARAGE.
ERODING ACCORDING TO THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT CRITERIA.
OVER 50% OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE
FAMILIES CURRENTLY FALL INTO
LOW INCOME CATEGORY. LESS THAN
80% OF MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME.
OVER ONE THIRD OF ALL
CONSTRUCTION FAMILIES ARE
CLASSIFIED AS VERY LOW INCOME
EARNING LESS THAN 50% OF THE
MEDIAN FAMILY INCOME. LIKE MANY
OTHER SECTORS CONSTRUCTION
WAGES HAVE GONE DOWN THE WAGE
THEFT IN CASH PAYMENTS HAVE
ALSO INCREASED. A KEY FACTOR
FOR THIS IS A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT OF BASIC LABOR LAWS
ON THE JOB SITE. UNSCRUPULOUS
CONTRACTORS DO NOT PLAY BY THE
RULES. AND HAVE ILLEGAL AND
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE OVER ON ITS
CONTRACTORS AND UNDERMINED
WAGES AND WORKING CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE INDUSTRY. LABOR
SHORTAGES IN CONSTRUCTION ARE
LARGELY CONCENTRATED IN LOW
WAGE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
SECTORS OF THE INDUSTRY. I DO
NOT NEED TO GO INTO DETAIL WHY
THAT IS DANNY CURTAIN WHO'S
HERE WITH ME TODAY WE'LL DO
THAT. BUT I WILL SHARE THAT
WILL SEVENTEEN OH ONE BY
FUHRMAN WHICH TOOK EFFECT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HAS MADE
SOME DIFFERENCES IT IS NOT DONE
ENOUGH SOME CONTRACTORS STILL
CONSIDER WAGE THEFT TO JUST BE
A COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
COLLEAGUES AT THIS TIME THAT WE
TREAT WAITSTAFF IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY SIMILAR
TO HOW WE TREAT IT AND OTHER
INDUSTRIES. SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN WILL PROVIDE NECESSARY
FORSMAN TOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY
DETER CONTINUED WAGE THEFT BY
ENSURING THAT DIRECT
CONTRACTORS NO LONGER IGNORE
THE VIOLATIONS OF THE
SUBCONTRACTORS THEY HIRE. WITH
THEIR PROJECTS FOR THE PROJECTS
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS DANNY
CURTAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONFERENCE OF CARPENTERS AND
WHEN APPROPRIATE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR- MR
CURTAIN THANK YOU SENATE LABOR
AND THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE- MEMBERS. ALTERNATIVE
REPEAT SOME OF THE STUFF FROM
THE SENATE DELIVER SAID BUT
I'LL DO MY BEST. IN THE TIME
ALLOTTED I WANT TO POINT OUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND PERHAPS AT
THE END IF I DON'T GET THROUGH
ALL THIS YOU CAN ASK ME
QUESTIONS. HOW BAD THE WAGE
THAT PROBLEM ACTUALLY IS SENATE
LABORTOUCHED ON THAT THE
DAMAGE IS CREATED ON THE WORK
FORCE AND HONEST CONTRACTORS.
HOW POOR THE ENFORCEMENT IS A
HUNDRED YEARS OF LEGAL
PRECEDENT FOR JOINT LIABILITY
THE LEGAL PRECEDENT NOW THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE WHY THE
DIRECT CONTRACTOR SHOULD BE
HELD RESPONSIBLE. THE HOUSING
CRISIS. CANNOT BE SOLVED WITH
UNSKILLED UNMOTIVATED
IMPOVERISHED WORKERS. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REPORT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S BUREAU
FIELD ENFORCEMENT DESCRIBED THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AS RAMPANT
WIDESPREAD UNCONSTRAINED OUT OF
CONTROL. THE CONCENTRATED IN
FOR INTEREST IT'S CONCENTRATED
IN FOR INDUSTRIES CONSTRUCTION
AGRICULTURE RESTAURANT AND
GARMENT I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE AND SENATOR DORADO
FIRST SB SIXTY TWO ASSEMBLY
JOINT LABOR LIABILITY BILL FOR
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY THAT WAS
PASSED ABOUT A MONTH AGO. THINK
OF CONSTRUCTION IS A STACK OF
FOUR CATEGORIES ALL RELATIVELY
SIMILAR IN SIZE THIS IS
IMPORTANT ALL ABOUT THE SAME
SIZE THE TOP TWO CATEGORIES
INCLUDE PUBLIC WORKS. AND THE
LARGER MORE COMPLEX PRIVATE
PROJECTS. UNION AND NONUNION
CONTRACTORS COMPETE FOR THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKERS
THEY NEED TO BUILD THESE
PROJECTS. PUBLIC WORKS REQUIRES
THE MOST RIGOROUS STANDARDS TO
ATTRACT AND KEEP WORKERS ON THE
PRIVATE JOBS CONTRACTORS HAVE
TO MEET OR COME CLOSE TO
MATCHING PUBLIC WORK STANDARDS.
THAT'S A HEALTHY COMPETITION
AND A TOUGH MARKET PLACE. THE
BOTTOM HALF IS EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE. I WAS CONTRACTORS THE
PLAY BY THE RULES IN THE LOW
WAGE NONUNION SECTOR. COMPETE
WITH A BOTTOM FEEDERS IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY WHERE THE
RULES GO OUT THE WINDOW THEY
FACE CASH PAID LABOR BROKERS
PEACE WORK. NO OVERTIME PAY AND
WORST OF ALL. OFTEN NO PAYROLL
RECORDS. THAT'S A CANCEROUS AND
DESTRUCTIVE COMPETITION IN A
VICIOUS MARKET PLACE IT DRIVES
WAGES AND WORKING FISHING
CONDITIONS OF THE BOTTOM.
WORKERS HAVE NO SAY NO CHOICE
AND A CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE. I'M
A CONTRACTOR FOR DRIVEN OF
BUSINESS. IN THE LAST FIVE
DECADES THE BOTTOM FEEDERS IN
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY HAVE
INCREASED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
PERCENT. IT'S CREATED A SUB
CLASS OF WORKERS KEPT IN
POVERTY. FOR THE BOTTOM OF THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY MARKET
PLACE CRIME DOES PAY. ACCORDING
TO CENSUS DATA. SENATE LABOR
TOUCHED ON. THE LOW INCOME VERY
LOW INCOME OR EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME OR THE MAJORITY OF
WORKERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
MARKET. IN THE UPPER HALF OF
THE MARKET PLACE THAT'S RARELY%
THE CASE. IN THE BOTTOM HALF
THEY MAKE LESS THAN FIFTY CENTS
ON THE DOLLAR COMPARED TO
WORKERS IN THE FORMAL HONEST
ECONOMY. THE FURTHER DOWN YOU
GO INTO THE BOTTOM HALF OF THE
INDUSTRY THE HIGHER THE
CONCENTRATION. OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR. IN THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY ITSELF THE BOTTOM 25%
IT IS OVER 85% OF THE WORKFORCE.
AT THE VERY LOW END OF THE
INCOME LADDER THAT'S THE
DAMAGE. IN ONE HUNDRED NINETY
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
GOVERNMENT ENFORCEMENT IS
VALIANT BUT FEW TILE. YOUR
CHANCES OF BEING INVESTIGATED
BY THE LABOR COMMISSIONER OR
ONCE EVERY THREE HUNDRED YEARS.
YOUR CHANCES OF BEING
INVESTIGATED BY THE MULTI
AGENCY JOINT FORSMAN STRIKE
FORCE ARE ONCE EVERY THREE
THOUSAND YEARS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE BUREAU FIELD
ENFORCEMENT REPORTED TWENTY IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS OF WAGES ILLEGALLY
REPORTED OR NOT REPORTED AT ALL.
IN A HUNDRED NINETY ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY. THEY ASESSED
ONLY EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN PENALTIES IN WAGES
AND THEY COLLECTED SIX HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS JUST 80% OF WHAT THEY
ASSESSED AGAIN IN A HUNDRED
NINETY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
WE'RE CHEATING IS OUT OF
CONTROL. THAT'S THE
ENFORCEMENT. THE JOINT
LIABILITY STANDARD AND SEVEN SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN AND SENATOR
DHIRAJ ROOMS BILL BEGAN OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. IT TOOK DEAD
AND MANGLED CHILDREN IN THE
TEXTILE FACTORIES TO FINALLY
PASSED THAT LAW AND AFTER YEARS
OF FOR THE STRUGGLE IT FINALLY
WORKED. OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS THE NEW
SUBLETT CLASS OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. NEED THAT STANDARD.
HONEST CONTRACTORS NEED THAT
STANDARD AND IT ALREADY EXISTS
IN CALIFORNIA IN PUBLIC WORKS
CONSTRUCTION CONSTRUCTION
EXCUSE ME. WHEN GOVERNMENT
BILLS UNLIKE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
THE SERVICE THE CONSUMER THE
REGULATOR AND ENFORCER. THEY
SET THE HIGHEST STANDARDS IN
THE INDUSTRY GOVERNMENT WANTS
THE PROP THEIR PROJECTS WELL
DESIGNED AND BUILT TO LAST WITH
WORKERS THAT MAKE GOOD WAGES
AND BENEFITS AND WORK ON SAFE
JOB SITES THEY DON'T TELL
TOLERATE OR TURN A BLIND EYE A
BIT CONTRACTORS THAT'S THE
PRESIDENT. THE GENERAL CONTRACT
CONTRACT IS FULLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SAFETY AND SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF A PROJECT. IF
IT'S NOT THEN RIGHT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE. IF THE WINDOWS ARE
UPSIDE DOWN THEY DON'T SAY
SORRY. IT WAS A SUBCONTRACTOR'S
FAULT THAT THE ONLY ENTITY THAT
HAS THE ABILITY THE TOOLS AND
THE AUTHORITY AND NOW WE WOULD
SAY THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
MONITOR ALL ASPECTS OF THE
PROJECT. SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN AND
JOINT LIABILITY IS NOT A MAGIC
CURE TO THE CANCER OF THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY IT IS A BIG
STEP BIDWILL TO STILL TAKE
YEARS TO CHANGE THE WILD WEST
CULTURE AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
INDUSTRY. SB SEVEN TWO SEVEN IS
NOT A WAGE BILL. IT'S NOT A
WAGE BILL. IT'S A PLAY BY THE
RULES BILL IT'S A WAGE THEFT
BILL CONTRACTORS ARE CORRUPT
REQUIRED RIGHT NOW BY LAW TO
KEEP PAYROLL RECORDS. THAT TIME
SHE RECORDS IT'S NOT TOO MUCH
TO ASK. NO MORE LOOKING THE
OTHER WAY NO MORE FINGER
POINTING NO MORE SAYING IT'S
SOMEONE ELSE'S FAULT IT'S TIME
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO GET
THEIR HOUSE IN ORDER AND PLAY
BY THE RULES. ONE LAST THOUGHT.
YOU ARE FACING A CRISIS WITH A
TALL ORDER OF BUILDING THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION NEW HOUSING
UNITS. WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
THE INDUSTRY CLAIMS THEY DON'T
HAVE THE WORKERS. THEY WON'T
HAVE THE WORKERS AS LONG AS
YOUNG WORKERS SEE THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IS A
TOUGH DIRTY DANGEROUS JOB THAT
WILL LEAVE THEM IN POVERTY.
THAT WON'T CHANGE UNTIL YOUNG
WORKERS SEE THIS INDUSTRY AS
MORE THAN JUST BUILDING
STRUCTURES BUT AS A WAY TO
BUILD THE FUTURE. IT USED TO BE
THAT WAY AND IT SHOULD BE THAT
WAY AGAIN. SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN MATTERS AND WILL HELP ARE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND- BE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER BURTON. WE HAVE A. MR
LEE AS WELL MISTER DISMANTLING
BURKE IN LIGHT LEAD OPPOSITION-
IN ORDER SUPPORT WE HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE ON THE PHONE CASE
OR SOME TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF
THERE ARE OTHERS YOU WANT TO GO
TO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT HERE AND
YES ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WE STILL
HAVE RIGHT WE DO HAVE
DEFINITELY. IN SUPPORT- HE'S
HERE PROTECTING QUESTION OVER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS OKAY WHAT
ABOUT MISTER DAVID KIRSCH.
THANKS SAME THING. OKAY
BETTERTON RIGHT WILL HAVE WON
THE TWO PARK PERFECT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CAN BE
JEREMY SMITH EXCUSE ME JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL SUPPORTING THE
BILL AS AMENDED TO FIX THE
CONCERNS OF THE UA UNION WITH
THAT THE THOSE MEASUREMENTS ARE
TAKEN SO WE HEAR SUPPORT FOR
THOSE REASONS THANK YOU. INFIRM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AFTERNOON
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS AUGGIE BELTRAN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
REGIONAL COUNCIL. RESIDENTIAL
INDUSTRY IS RIFE WITH
CORRUPTION. THE WAIT STAFF
HAPPENS MOSTLY TO LATINO
WORKERS ON A DAILY BASIS. SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
ARE JUST AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. NOW
OKAY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES A
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SEEN NONE
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE INTO-
WITNESSES WAY TO JUSTIFY GET
THE TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
MODERATE YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN WHO BEGAN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WHEN THE
GENTLEMAN TO- SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU MODERATE AND IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT THEY ARE
QUEUING UP WE'RE CURRENTLY AT
SEVEN. IF YOU'RE READY WILL
GOING ON THE LINE FORTY SEVEN
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO IN. I
THINK YOU MENTIONED THIS IS
KEITH DONE WITH THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS I WOULD
JUST SUPPORT THE STATEMENTS BY
MR CURTAIN. AND THE MISTER
SMITH AND JUSTIN WERE
CONTINUING TO WATCH THIS BILL
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH. THE STAFF OF DOCTORS
OFFICE HE WAS MISTER CURTAIN
THAT JUST BILL MOVES ALONG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MARINO LINE NUMBER FIFTY HAVE
CLEANS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR A
TEMPERAMENT INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS WITH
AMENDMENTS WERE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SENATOR LEYVA UNITED
BROTHERHOOD OF CARPENTERS SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE GO NOW TO LINE
NUMBER THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
CAN YOU MENTAL MULTIPLE
CORPORATE LOCAL TWO ONE THREE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THANKS BE UNTO
THEM. THANK YOU GOING OUT TO
LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE
AIRLINES OPEN. THIS IS JOHN
HANNAH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE WE RENT SANTIAGO
DISTRICT AS WELL AS WITH THE
SOUTHWEST REGIONAL COUNCIL OF
CARPENTERS STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
TWO SIX SEVEN TWO SEVEN THIS IS
MR CURTAIN SAID AS A PLAY BY
THE RULES- BILL AND IT'LL HELP
DEAL WITH HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
MAKE PEOPLE PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE FOR VICTIMIZING
WORKFORCE. STRONGLY URGES
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NOT GOING TO
LIE NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINES OPEN. HELLO THIS IS SEAN
HEBARD- GOVERNOR'S LOCAL FIVE
OH FIVE IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND- I HEARD
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU GOING TO LINE THE
SIXTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. YES
MY NAME IS RICH GOMEZ ON THE
OPTION OF CARPENTERS UNION
LOCAL SEVEN ONE FOUR WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN.
SEVEN TWO SEVEN BECAUSE IT WILL
HELP CRACK DOWN ON BAD
CONTRACTORS THANK YOU. WE DID
GAIN ONE ADDITIONAL IN Q. ONCE
AGAIN FOR ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO NOW GOING
BLIND NUMBER FORTY TWO THE
LASSEN. MOMENT WHEN A PLACE.
BETTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONTY GONNA BE HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL. WANT TO THANK SENATOR
LEYVA FOR DRESSING OUR CONCERNS
WILL BE AMENDMENTS AND WE WILL
SUPPORT. SB. SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WITHOUT THE KEY WAS NOT CLEAR.
THANK YOU MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CHECK THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPER
WITNESSES FOR SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE. CERTAINLY IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN HAVE NOT
YET DONE SO PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLEASE. AND WITH THAT
PROMPTLY BECAUSE WE HAVE NO
ADDITIONAL CALLS IN QUEUE.
THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION. FOR
SB SEVEN FOR I'M SORRY SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN WE DO HAVE TO LEAD
OPPOSITIONS ON FILE SILVIA
FERRARI FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS SCOTT GOVERNOR.
BROWN THE GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATES- DO WE HAD MR SILVA
FERRARI ON THE LINE. NOT INSURE
LOW CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HELLO
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN THE BILL FOR
OUR AND AFTER CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
TODAY HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWO SEVEN I'M
MEASURE THAT HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED AS A HOUSING KILLER
BY THE CBI GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT WE ACTUALLY
FIND OURSELVES HAVING TO RE
OPEN WHAT WAS A FASHION LONG
DEBATE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN IN
REGARDS TO AB SEVENTEEN OH ONE
AND AT THAT TIME THE BILL
INITIALLY CONTAIN VERY SIMILAR
PROVISIONS TO THOSE IN SB SEVEN
TWO SEVEN. NAMELY THE PROVISION
SEEKING TO IMPOSE PENALTIES
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES ON HOME
BUILDERS FOR DIRECT CONTRACTORS
IN THOSE PROVISIONS WERE
REMOVED FROM SEVENTEEN OH ONE
GB I WENT NEUTRAL I DON'T EVEN.
LIQUIDATED DAMAGES ARE PUNITIVE.
VIRGINS ARE APPROACH WHEN YOU
ARE TRYING TO PUNISH THE
WRONGDOER MEMBERS PUNISH THE
WRONGDOER BECAUSE AN
INTENTIONAL WRONGDOING IS
COMMITTED. SO THERE IS FRAUD
THERE IS MALICE THERE IS
OPPRESSION COMMITTEE IN THE ACT.
IS NOT AND CANNOT BE THE CASE
WHEN THE PARTY WHO THIS BILL IS
ATTEMPTING TO PENALIZE
PUNITIVELY HOMEBUILDER THE
DIRECT CONTRACTOR DO DOES NOT
KNOW DOES NOT CONTROL THE
PAYMENT AND BILLING ACTIONS OF
THE SUBCONTRACTOR. AND AS YOU
HEARD THERE IS NO PUBLIC LIST
MADE AVAILABLE BY ANY PUBLIC
AGENCY THAT IDENTIFY BAD ACTORS
IF THE STATE WERE TO PUBLISH IN
THAT LIST. OUR MEMBERS WOULD
LOOK TO IT TO HELP INFORM THEIR
HIRING DECISIONS BUT SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN IN THIS BILL IS
EVEN GOING TO BE REMOTELY
WORKABLE AND NOT BANKRUPT
BUILDERS ESPECIALLY THOSE SMALL
MEDIUM BUILDERS INTO THE
FUTURE. YOU HAVE TO INCLUDE A
MEANINGFUL TEACHER OPPORTUNITY
THAT INSURERS WORKERS ARE PAID
WITH THEIR OWN IT INSURERS
HOMEBUILDERS AND DIRECT
CONTRACTORS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. HERE AND AVOID ANY
PENALTIES OR LIQUIDATED DAMAGES
BECAUSE AGAIN THEY WERE NOT THE
PARTY WHO COMMITTED THE
WRONGDOING. AND WHILE WE-APPRECIATE WHAT WE HEARD IN THE
ARTICULATION OF THE AMENDMENT.
THERE STILL SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
A LOT TO DO THERE TO MAKE THIS
BILL EVEN REMOTELY WORKABLE. SO
IN A MEETING COACH HERE IS NOT
INCORPORATED SEVENTY SEVEN IN
THIS BILL REALLY IS NOTHING
MORE THAN AN UPHOLSTERED VERY
WOULD YOU MIND CLOSING ON
THOSE. ON THOSE WHO DID NOT
COMMIT THE ACT AND THAT IS NOT
JUSTICE IN THE NAME OF WORKERS
SO WE ARE OPPOSED THIS IS A
HOUSING KELLER WE ARE VERY
HOPEFUL WE CAN WORK ON
AMENDMENTS MOVING FORWARD- BUT
WE ASK YOU KNOW ABOUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER FERRARI-
WE HAVE MISTER SCOTT GOVERNOR
IS HE. ON THE LINE PERCENT. I
DON'T MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES
GOVERNOR HOW SINCE EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION. OUR MEMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY. TO THE- LATE AND- AT
LIKE TO THINK THEY'RE NOT THE
TARGETS OF THIS BILL YET THEY
WOULD BE IMPACTED WE DO COULD
DID NEGOTIATE SEVENTEEN OH ONE
DIRECTLY WITH. THE PROPONENTS-
AND WE DID ADDRESS THE DAMAGES
AND PENALTIES THAN. FIFTEEN
MUCH REFERENCE TO THE PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS THE LABOR CODE
PROVISIONS THAT APPLY THERE.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS
THAT IT ONLY TAKES SOME OF
THOSE PROVISIONS. WE ACTUALLY
REQUESTED- OF THE CARPENTERS
AND SUGGESTED TO THE AUTHOR
THEY TAKE THE ENTIRE LABOR CODE
SECTION SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
IN TRANSFER THAT HERETHAT
PROVIDES TO PROCESS IT INSURES
THAT WORKERS GET PAID QUICKER.
UNFORTUNATELY AS PER THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OFFERED
TODAY ACCEPTED TODAY. THERE IS
NO ACTUAL RIGHT TO CURE. THE
CONTRACTOR GETS A NOTICE WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF SOMETIME COULD
BE A YEAR AFTER THE PROJECTS
DONE. THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION PERTAINING TO THE
ACTUAL WORKERS. YOU CAN'T Q. OR
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW. LABOR CODE
ADDRESSES THIS BECAUSE IT
REQUIRES THE I. R. TO NOTIFY
THE CONTRACTOR WITHIN FIFTEEN
DAYS. OF THE ACTUAL CLAIM WHAT
CONTRACTORS THEN DO AS THEY
SHUT DOWN THE SUBCONTRACTOR
THEY STOP PAYING THEM THEY
DEMAND THEY FIX IT OR THEY
TERMINATE THEM. WE THINK THAT'S
A FAR MORE PRODUCTIVE PROVISION
THAN THE RIGHT TO CURE HERE
WHICH AGAIN CANNOT BE
IMPLEMENTED IT WILL GET WORKERS
PAY. AND YOU KNOW WE WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR HAD A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH HER HAVE YOU
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CARPENTERS. BUT AGAIN AS THE
MOMENTS- WERE EXCEPT ACCEPTED
TODAY THEY DON'T FIX THE
PROBLEM SO THESE RESULTS-
REQUESTED HELP THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE INTO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SEEN NONE.
WELL NOW MOVES TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE THIS MODERATE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. WILL BE AGAIN. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF US
BEATS UP IN TWENTY SEVEN PRESS
ONE ZERO PLEASE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATE ONE WORD AT
THE RIGHT TIME PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AT SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN. CERTAINLY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. CURRENTLY WE HAVE TWO
IN Q. I'M GOING TO LINE NUMBER
SIXTY EIGHT LINES OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JAMIE
CONVERT THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS AND WE APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
SO BY. IN THE COMMITTEE BUT
UNFORTUNATE IS CURRENTLY ARE
STILL OPPOSED UNTIL THEIR
PROJECT. THANK YOU. NOW WE'LL
GO TO LINE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
YOU LINES OPEN PLEASE GOING TO.
MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY BERNACCHI A MAP
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE OF THE PLUMBING
HEATING AND PIPING INDUSTRY THE
NATIONAL MEDICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. AND UNITED
CONTRACTORS- ALL THESE
ORGANIZATIONS WERE ORIGINALLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL PART OF THE
MEASURE- AS ORIGINALLY IN
FRENCH- BUT IN LIGHT OF THE
COMMITMENTS THAT THE CENTER
LEYVA HAS AGREED TO TAKE- WE
BELIEVE THE BILL IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BOTH-
CENTER LEYVA AND THE SPONSORS-
MOVING FORWARD TO GET THIS BILL
IN A GOOD PLACE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. BUT AGAIN ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN HAVE NOT YET DONE SO
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO. WE HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL COMING INTO Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WILL BE TEN
SECONDS AGREEMENT NUMBER. TO
OPENING NOW LINE NUMBER FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD EVENING ASHLEY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. IN THE
QUEUE IS NOW CLEAR. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WOULD YOU MIND
CHECKING THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
ALL WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
CERTAINLY MEANT I'M SURE ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN HAVE NOT YET DONE SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WITH THE APARTMENT
I'M SURE THAT HE WAS STILL
EMPTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR IT WOULD WE'VE JUST
BECOME AWARE THAT THERE WERE
SOME WITNESSES WHO WERE
WAITING- TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND I KNOW THIS IS NOT PROTOCOL
BUT- WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE EVERYONE. AND GIVE
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK SPECIALLY IN IN LIGHT OF
OUR CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WERE
WORKING WITHIN THE COMMITTEES-
WOULD YOU MIND CHECKING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT SB SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. BUT CERTAIN
AMOUNT I'M SURE ONCE AGAIN
PRESS ONE ZERO TO COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
IF YOU HAVE NOT DONE SO
ALREADY. BERMAN IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN PRESS ONE
ZERO PLEASE. WAITING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN AND NOT GET THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS IS THE TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. HELLO
CALLER SECURA. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MODERATOR FOR ACCOMMODATING
THE REQUEST WE WANT TO THANK
ALL OF THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOT
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS TO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. YES
CENTER TO RAZA THREE COMMAND
CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- VERY MUCH AND THE
CARPENTER'S SON AND EVERYONE
WHO'S WORKING ON THIS YOU KNOW
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO- WE HEARD
ABOUT GARMENT WORKERS AN ENTIRE
INDUSTRY WHERE THEY EXPLODED
THROUGH PEACE WORK IT'S THE
MODEL OF. THE INDUSTRY. UP
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT PORT TRUCKERS
BEING MISCLASSIFIED ENTIRE
INDUSTRY THAT'S IMPACTED. TODAY
WE HEAR ABOUT THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AND THE WAGE THEFT
THAT IS STILL GOING ON- AND
THEN ALL THREE OF THESE
INDUSTRIES THE MAJORITY OF THE
WORKERS. IN NON BETTER INCLUDED
IN THAT ARE LATINOS. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF WORKERS IN THOSE
THREE INDUSTRIES ARE LATINOS. I
WONDER WHY 80% OF THE CHILDREN
IN L. A. U. S. T. QUALIFY FOR
FREE OR REDUCED MEALS. 80% OF
THE KIDS. SO THESE ARE YOU KNOW
THOSE SAME KIDS LIVE IN
OVERCROWDED HOUSING THOSE SAME
KIDS UGH- ARE FACING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE. EXTER LEARNING
LOSS BEYOND WHAT OTHERS- THESE
ARE THESE ARE ISSUES THAT IS
NOT JUST ABOUT A FEW WORKERS
HERE AND THERE THESE ARE THESE
ARE ENTIRE INDUSTRIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE GOT
TO DO BETTER AND I'M A REALLY
YOU KNOW OF WAS GLAD TO SEE MR
GOVERNOR HERE AND OTHERS WHO-
ARE HAVE SPOKEN OUT AND SAID
THAT THEY'RE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. AND WITH THE
CARPENTERS- WE CAN'T GO ON AS A
STATE LIKE THIS- WE THEN ARE
HAVING TO SUBSIDIZE OUR TAX
DOLLARS WE'RE HAVING TO
SUBSIDIZE ALL THOSE FAMILIES
THROUGH A SAFETY NET OR BY-
PAYING FOR THOSE MEALS FOR
THOSE CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN THE
POVERTY- WE HAVE GOT TO CHANGE
THESE SYSTEMS DRAMATICALLY. SO
THAT TAXPAYERS DON'T HAVE TO
KEEP PUTTING THE BILL ON AND IT
JUST IS VERY UPSETTING THAT WE
KEEP HAVING TO DEAL WITH THESE
INDUSTRIES SO I PLUGGED THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
TAKING THE STEPS THANK YOU
CENTER DRAWS OF. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUSSELL CENTER NEWMAN
AT THANK YOU MEMBERSHIP. SO-
RELATED YOU FOR ALL HARD WORK
ON THIS HARD BILL. I I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS OVER LAST WEEK-
WHICH HAS TO BE JUST A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE TIME YOU SPENT-
AND WE COMMEND YOU AND THE
CHEER. FOR MAKING YOURSELVES SO
AVAILABLE TO BOTH SIDES AND I
AND I'M GONE I'M GONE I'M
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
STILL WORKING. WITH OPPOSITION
SO- I AM SYMPATHETIC TO THE
BROADER COMPLAIN OF THE CIA AND
OTHER FOLKS. THAT THERE ISN'T
CURRENTLY A SYSTEMIC ABILITY TO
TRACK BAD ACTORS- AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE THEIR CONCERN ABOUT
IT YOU KNOW THE APPROPRIATE
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE. YOU KNOW
UNDER THE CONTEXT IS CREATED.
TO IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND RIGHT
JUST TO REITERATE BECAUSE LIKE
I'M ACTUALLY NOT A BIG FAN OF
HOW WE DO THIS DURING THE
PANDEMIC I THINK IT LOSES A LOT
OF THE TRANSLATION. AND SOME OF
THIS IS ACTUALLY QUITE
COMPLICATED AND QUITE SUBTLE.
AND SERVE YOU COULD SPEAK A
LITTLE BIT TO WHERE THE BILL IS
RIGHT NOW- THE AMENDMENT YOU'VE
TAKEN SO FAR BUT THEN MOVING
FORWARD. I DI DI AM SURE OF
YOUR INTENT. TO TRY AND MEET
THE NEEDS. OR THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION AS YOU MOVE IT
FORWARD. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN AND WELL THIS IS
CONVOLUTED AT TIMES. THE BILL
IS REALLY PRETTY PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT WAGE THEFT IS
NOT A COST OF DOING BUSINESS.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK
TODAY HELP REMOVE SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE OF CONCERNS
ABOUT UNEMPLOYMENT AND THER
CONCERNS ABOUT. WORKERS
COMPENSATION- THE LAST PART OF
THE MA'AM WE TOOK WOULD REQUIRE
NOTICES TO BE FILED WITH THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD. WHICH WOULD TRACK THE
WAGE THAT VIOLATION ON THE
ORIGINAL EMPLOYERS LICENSE. AND
JOINT LIABILITY FOR WAGE
VIOLATION PENALTIES COULD APPLY
IF THREE NOTICES ARE FILED.
WITHIN A THREE YEAR PERIOD BUT
AS ARM YOU HEARD ME SAY IN MY
OPENING WE WERE NOT ABLE TO.
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- WE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WE CAN FINISH THE
CONVERSATION BILLS FOR THAT
WAY. AND RIGHT TO CURRENT
WORKING ON A RIGHT TO CURE IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO. EVERYONE
INVOLVED SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
IF THIS BILL GETS OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY. WORKING WITH
ALL STATE FOR BONDHOLDERS
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AS WE GO
TO THE NEXT COMMITTEE WHICH
WOULD BE JUDICIARY. I LIKE TO
SAY THAT A GOOD NEGOTIATION
MEANS EVERYBODY WALKS AWAY A
LITTLE BIT HAPPY. AND A LITTLE
BIT UNHAPPY SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS AND
MAKING SURE WORKERS ARE PAID
FAIRLY. I PROJECT I'VE HEARD
YOU SAY THAT IN MANY CASES. SO
YOU KNOW WITH THAT IN MIND SO I
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY BUT I DOUBT I WOULD URGE
YOU. TO CONTINUE WORKING. WITH
THE SUPPORTERS- WITH THEIR
SPONSORS WITH THE OPPOSITION
BUT I THINK I THINK YOU'RE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK- AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT YOU CAN GET TO A-
A BIT LEAST. NEUTRAL ON THE
OTHER SIDE. TWO FOUR TWO THANK
YOU THANK CENTER NEWMAN. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE OTHER COMMENTS
FROM. THE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER LEYVA AT THIS
TIME I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
YOUR THE BIL AT THIS TIME BUT
I AM EXCITED TO HEAR THAT YOU
ARE WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS I BELIEVE THAT- IN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS WILL DO
MUCH BETTER WHEN WE DO HAVE
BALANCE POLICIES. MOVING
FORWARDS AND HAVING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
EFFORTS YOU PART IN A FORWARD
EXCITED TO HEAR THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH EVERYBODY AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
BILL- AND- FOR THE FOR. THE- AT
THIS TIME WILL HAVE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WE HAVE A
MOTION. OKAY I'M SORRY YES WE
DO NEED A MODE YES WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR JOSH NEWMAN
TALKS SENATOR NEWMAN. IT WAS
IMPORTANT BEFORE THE VOTE. YES
I APOLOGIZE IT'S ONCE ALREADY
YOU KNOW IT IT'S LATE I'M SORRY
HAVEN'T HAD LUNCH YET- SO WE DO
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
NEWMAN CONSULTING PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
BE RE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SENATOR CORTEZ E.
SENATOR A CHOPPER OAK NOW UNDER
A CHOP BOGUE NO SENATOR TORONTO.
SENATOR ALSO HI SENATOR LAYERED
HI. SENATOR LAYERED HI SENATOR
NEWMAN SENATOR NEWMAN FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH M. WE DO
HAVE FOUR VOTES AND IN THREE
AND ONE. THREE ENDS IN SUPPORT
ONE IN OPPOSITION WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER LEYVA THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS. SENATOR PAN.
IF. THE
AIRPORT. VERY HELLO WELCOME
SENATOR PAN YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BIO ON S. P. FOR TWENTY OR
TWENTY TWO. YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR- MEMBERS-
PLEASED TO BE HERE TO PRESENT
SB FOUR TWENTY TWO A BILL THAT
WILL IMPROVE PATIENT CARE AND
HEALTH OUTCOMES BY EXTENDING
WORKFORCE FLEXIBILITY THE CIVIL
SERVICE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
CURRENT LABOR LAW LIMITS THE
AMOUNT OF HOURS A CIVIL SERVICE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL CAN
PERFORM BEFORE THE STATE IS
REQUIRED TO UTILIZE A
CONTRACTOR PROVISIONAL SERVICES
AND UNDER THE CURRENT MODEL
CONTRACTORS IN COSTA STATE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE. THAN
COMPARED TO OTHER CIVIL SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS PATIENTS ALSO CAN
SUFFER DUE TO GAPS IN CARE FROM
THEIR TRUSTED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL. THE STATE HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAINTAIN A
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR ITS
PATIENTS AT STATE HOSPITALS AND
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. THESE
INSTITUTIONS CURRENTLY SUFFERS
FROM HIGH VACANCY RATES AMONGST
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AS OF JULY TWENTY
TWENTY DATA REVEALS A VACANCY
RATE OF 29% AMONG ALL STATE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS. THE
VACANCY RATE AND FOR OTHER
STATE DEPARTMENTS EMPLOYING
PHYSICIANS CAN RANGE FROM FORTY
SEVEN TO EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT.
SB FOUR TWENTY TWOS MODELED
AFTER A SUCCESSFUL PILOT
PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS
IMPROVED PATIENT OUTCOMES FOR
THE COUNTY. SB FOUR TWENTY TO
SIX DEGREES TO CREATE A
POSITION AMERICAN PROFESSIONAL
REGISTRY THEY'LL ENCOURAGE
SCHEDULING FLEXIBILITY AND
GREATER PATIENT COVERAGE
FOLLOWING MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
TO REPAY MAIN AT THEIR PLACE OF
EMPLOYMENT. THIS BILL ALSO
CONTAINS PROVISIONS FOR CALLIE
CHARGES TABLETS TO REGISTRY BY
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY IN ADDITION
EACH STATE AGENCY EMPLOYING
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS FROM THE
REGISTRY MUST CONDUCT REPORT
STUDY THE EFFECTIVENESS AND
COST SAVINGS AT THE REGISTRY BY
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL WILL
SUNSET ON JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME DR
STUART BUSSY PRESIDENT OF THE
UNION AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
DENTISTS TO TESTIFY ON THIS
ISSUE AND TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ARE
SPECIALLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
LEAD AT SUPPORT WITNESS WITH
DOCTORS STOURTON. ABBASI THANK
YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME YES SIR.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI
MY NAME IS DR STEWART BUT SHE
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNION
OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS ASKED ME LOCAL TWO OH
SIX. AND I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR TWENTY TWO.
TO HEAR THIS BILL WILL GO A
LONG WAY TOWARDS PROVIDING
BETTER CONTINUITY OF HEALTH
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA'S INMATES.
AND HOSPITALIZE MENTALLY ILL.
IT WILL SAVE TAXPAYERS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
CONTRACTING OUT STATE EMPLOYEE
HEALTH CARE POSITIONS HAS
REMAINED A PROBLEM FOR DECADES
IN CALIFORNIA. IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE I TESTIFIED AND
RECOMMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE. CAN PRACTICAL
SOLUTIONS TO MITIGATE THIS
PROBLEM BUT NONE HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED. BUT I AM MORE HOPEFUL
NOW. THE STATE AND THE UNION
HAVE COLLABORATED IN A
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION STUDY
OVER THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS.
THAN IN THIS REPORT STATISTICS
SHOW A STEADILY INCREASING
AMOUNT OF MONEY BEING SPENT ON
PRIVATE HEALTH CARE
CONTRACTORS. GET BACK SO THE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POSITION VACANCIES NCDC R. AND
D. S. H. DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. WHAT CONTRACT MADE
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AT
ACDC OUR PRISON IN ONE MONTH.
THE STATE PAYS CONTRACTORS
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR BARGAINING UNIT
SIXTEEN WORK AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS MORE WHEN CONTRACTING
OUT BARGAINING UNIT NINETEEN
PSYCHOLOGISTS. SOCIAL WORKERS
PHARMACISTS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST. BUT COLEMAN COURT
SPECIAL MASTERS REPORT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
RECOMMENDED BETTER SALARY
OPPORTUNITIES TO RETAIN OUR
STATE POSITIONS. ARE YOU A DUTY
AS PREVIOUSLY NEGOTIATED
ADDITIONAL APPOINTMENT LANGUAGE
IN ITS MO YOU WITH THE STATE
BUDGET IS DISCRETIONARY ON THE
PART OF THE STATE AND THE STATE
HAS NOT BEEN- TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THIS LANGUAGE AND HAS BEEN
HESITANT TO DO SO. EVENTUALLY
NEED FOR SB FOUR TWENTY TWO. A
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE OF AN
EMPLOYEE REGISTRY WOULD ENSURE
AN EFFECTIVE SYSTEM IT'S A BY
MORE RELIABLE HEALTHCARE AT A
MUCH LOWER COST. STATE
EMPLOYEES IN CONTRAST TO
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS ALREADY
KNOW THEIR PATIENTS ALREADY
KNOW THEIR INSTITUTIONS. THEY
WOULD PROVIDE BETTER CONTINUITY
OF CARE. THAT 110035% OF THEIR
BASE SALARY THAT'S A BARGAIN
COMPARED TO THE CONTRACTORS
RATE OF 2100% HIS PROPOSED
REGISTRY WILL BE MODELED AFTER
THE SUCCESSFUL LOS ANGELES
COUNTY REGISTRY THOSE REGISTRY
PROFESSIONALS THEIR PATIENTS
ARE HAPPY. AND THE COUNTY OF
SAVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. SO AT
THE FORT SB FOUR TWENTY TWO
REGISTRIES CAN ACCOMPLISH THE
SAME RESULTS FOR THE STATE. I
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTES ON THIS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MY
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ANOTHER READ
SUPPORT WITNESS. THERE ARE NONE
OKAY WE WILL ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY SUPPORT WITH. ON THIS BLL
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM AT THIS
TIME IF SO. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THREE NINE NINE WILL CHECK THE
OVERFLOW ROOM AS SEEN ON THERE
TO SPEAK WILL GO TO THE
TELECOMS OPERATOR ASKED THE
MODERATOR TO QUEUE UP- ANY-
SUPPORT WITNESSES. IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL THIS TIME- FAVORITE
UP WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. WE
HAVE DOING QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEIR LINE. BUT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
QUICK STOP MAYOR CALLING WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU.
MONTHS AGAIN AFTER OF-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
TWENTY TWO PLEASE. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE INTO THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU ROOM MODERATOR
FREESHEET THAT- I DID NOT SEE
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS ON THIS
BILL SO. HOW WE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL C. NONE
WILL GO TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM
SCENE AND THEY'RE BACK TO THE
MODERATOR. OF THIS MOTOR CAN
YOU. ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK TO THE
TELECONFERENCES. FROM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR TWENTY TWO PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE THEN ASK IF
THERE'S SUCH COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- METAL BY SURE. I DO
HAVE A QUESTION- SENATOR PAN
IT'S WITH REGARDS TO THE
CONVERSATION HERE IT IT MIGHT
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY THAT. THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE REGISTER
COULD WORK NO MORE THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A WEEK. AND A
COMPETITION IT WOULD BE A 135%
ABOVE THEIR HOURLY RATE. OPEN
UP. THE BASICALLY WITH THIS
REGISTRY WILL ALLOW- STATE-
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO BE ABLE
TO- BASICALLY COVER FROM FITS
OF YOUR YEP YOUR DOCTOR YOU
HAVE YET TO BE SURE Vì HAVE
SOMEONE STAFFING AT ALL THE
TIME IS RIGHT TO BE SURE PEOPLE
THAT THAT THE PEOPLE OF ACCESS
AND SO- SO THIS REGISTRY WILL
ALLOW US TO HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE WORKFORCE
AND DEAL BE SURE WE CAN PROVIDE
THE COVERAGE BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO USE
CONTRACTORS WHICH IS WAS
MENTION. COST ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
PERCENT- ON AVERAGE OF THE
ACTUAL CURRENT PAY OF THE- OF
THE CURRENT- THE CIVIL SERVICE-
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS BUT YES
THERE IS BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING
EXTRA WORK THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL- PAGE INCREASE FOR
PROVIDING THIS ADDITIONAL
COVERAGE- SO FOR THOSE OF THEM
WHO MAY BE WONDERING IF TO BE
EITHER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS OR A HUNDRED AND
35% ABOUT THE HOURLY RATE OR
TWO HUNDRED PERCENT. IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE THIS REGISTRIES ARE
IS THAT WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING
CORRECT RIGHT SO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE YOUNG SO YOU HAVE TO DO
YOUR REGULAR JOB FIRST RIGHT.
SO YES. YES THESE ARE ONLY FOR
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
REGISTRY THERE ARE GOING TO BE
ON. DOING THAT- OKAY. I THINK
THAT'LL FOR ME RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OF ANYTHING ELSE
OR ANYONE ELSE. IN TERMS OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THEM I
WILL GO BACK TO SENATOR PAN FOR
YOUR CLOTHES PLEASE. THANK YOU
AGAIN THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO BOTH SAVE MONEY AND
PROVIDE BETTER QUALITY SERVICE
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE WILL MOVE BY CENTER
NEWMAN- WE CAN GO TO ROLL CALL
VOTE POLICE TO THE CONSULTANT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
BY SENATOR CORTEZ THE AYE
SENATOR OCHO BOKE. SO SENATOR
DORADO HI CENTER LAYERED HI
AND- LAYERED HI SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN HI. THE BOK WAS
FOUR TO ONE- IN FAVOR OF THE
MOTION SO THE BILL WAS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
READY TO MOVE ON TO S. B. FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN- THIS WOULD BE
SENATOR PORTANTINO WE'RE JUST
GOING TO GET THE- SAAREMAA
HOUSEKEEPING DONE. HERE KEVIN
COLBERT NINETEEN BEFORE THIS
COULD SENATOR COMES FORWARD.
CENTER PORTANTINO. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PRESENT ON SB FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AS THE CHAIR
SAID I'M HERE FOR SB FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN THAT WILL FURTHER
CALIFORNIA'S- DIVEST MAN
EFFORTS FROM THE TURKISH
GOVERNMENT- MANY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES OF. THE CITY OF
GLENDALE BOTH IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE CITY ARE
DESCENDANTS OF ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE SURVIVORS. MOST OF
THEM RECENTLY I'VE HAD TO RE RE
LIVE THE INTERNATIONAL TRAUMA.
DURING THE RECENT EVENTS IN THE
ARTSAKH WAR IN WHICH TURKEY WAS
HEAVILY INVOLVED. THANK OF
BEING THE DESCENDANT OF
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE VICTIM. AND
THEN THINK OF THE ATTACKS ON
ETHNIC REGION OF THE WORLD
WHERE YOU MAY HAVE A COUSIN. OR
A SISTER. OR NEPHEW WHO EITHER
FOUGHT IN THE WAR OR DIED IN
THE WAR. AND NOW THINK OF YOUR
HARD EARNED. WAGES AS A CITY
EMPLOYEE OR A SCHOOL TEACHER.
AND A PERCENTAGE OF YOUR WAGES
GOING TO THE COUNTRY WHO
PERPETRATED THE FIRST GENOCIDE
OF THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
AND THEN SUPPORTED THE RECENT
ATTACK. ON ARTS SHOCK- I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US. WOULD FEEL
GOOD ABOUT. THAT SITUATION THE
THOUGHT OF HAVING YOUR WAGES
BEING INVESTED IN THE COUNTRY.
THE FRONT DESK TO YOUR FAMILY.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING SO
THIS BILL SEEKS TO FIND A
CREATIVE SOLUTION TO THAT
PROBLEM BY ALLOWING CITY OF
GLENDALE EMPLOYEES OR SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES OF THE
GLENDALE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. POPPED OUT OF THAT-
THE INVESTMENT PORTFOLIO
FRANKLY THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT IS. RELATIVE TO THE
PERSON STIRS OVERALL PORTFOLIO.
IT'S NOT GIGANTIC YOU KNOW 70%
OF THOSE INVESTMENTS FRANKLY
ARE U. S. INVESTMENTS- BUT-
JUST THE SHEER THOUGHT THE
OUTRAGE TO KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
COMPATRIOTS WHO ARE BEING HELD
AS PRISONERS OF WAR TODAY. AND
THERE ARE CHURCHES AND SCHOOLS
AND HOMES THAT WERE SEIZED LAST
YEAR- I'VE BEEN TO THAT REGION
THREE TIMES. I ACTUALLY WENT TO
A WEDDING AND A BEAUTIFUL WHITE
CATHEDRAL IN THE TOWN OF SHUSHI.
WHICH IS NOW BEEN SEIZED BY THE
AZERBAIJANIS. AND THE CHURCH
HAS BEEN DESTROYED- IT'S JUST
NOT RIGHT. AND IT'S NOT RIGHT
FOR PURCHASERS TO INVEST IN THE
GOVERNOR TURKEY FIRST AND
FOREMOST BECAUSE IT CONTINUES
TO DENY THE GENOCIDE. AND THEN
SECONDLY FOR THE ATROCITIES
THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE IN OUR
TALK OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
WITH ME TODAY ON THE PHONE WE
HAVE- WE THE DIVIDEND FROM THE
ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF
AMERICA WESTERN REGION AND MEET
ON THE MARGINS FROM THE
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY AND I KNOW
ONE OF MY WE TOOK ME TO
WITNESSES AS COUNCIL MEMBER.
PARTY TO SAKIN FROM GLENDALE
WHO'S BROUGHT THIS IDEA TO ME-
AND I'M GOING TO ASK HIM A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ONCE HE DOES
HIS ME TOO SO- THANK YOU FOR
HEARING OUT THIS IMPORTANT.
STORY AND WHY IS THIS RELEVANT
TO CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THERE'S
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ARMENIAN AMERICANS WHO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE ALL OF WHOM ARE
DESCENDANTS OF THE FIRST
GENOCIDE OF THE TWENTIETH
CENTURY SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL WHEN APPROPRIATE AND
PLEASE HEAR FROM MY TWO
WITNESSES. THANK YOU SENATOR IN
AT THE OUTSET WE ESTABLISHED
THE- LEAST OF WHICH TIME
PERIODS OF TWO MINUTES PER. OF
WITNESS- WITH- UP TO TWO
WITNESSES ON EITHER SIDE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION- THIS IS. IN
REGARD TO LEAD WITNESSES SO
WE'LL GO TO THE FIRST LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS AND IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE US YOU JUST SELF
IDENTIFY IN YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LEONID AND
I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
ARMENIAN NATIONAL COMMITTEE OF
AMERICA WESTERN REGION. I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO. FOR
ME TO PROVIDE MY REMARKS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIXTY SEVEN.
DEPEND BUT HE CONTINUED HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES POLICY OF
GENOCIDE DENIAL A DELIBERATE
ACT IN OPPOSITION TO THE UNITED
STATES. BUT INTRODUCED BY THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE REPUBLIC OF
TURKEY OUR ORGANIZATION. AND
BILLION SUPPORT SB FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN. IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE. OF AB
THIRTEEN. AND WE'RE MONDAY
DURING. THE UNITED CONGRESS WE
BIPARTISAN AND ALL BILL SUPPORT.
RECOGNIZING GENOCIDE OVER TIME
YOU IN VARIOUS GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD HAVE
RECOGNIZED THE GENOCIDE AND
HAVE URGED TURKEY TO DO THE
SAME HOWEVER NOT ONLY TURKEY
HAS FAILED TO RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE. IT HAS CONTINUED TO
BE ATROCITIES. AGAINST THE
ARMENIAN. TWENTY ONE AUDIO THE
NEW AGAINST ARMENIAN ARE
TALKING PERSONALLY KNOWN AS
LOCAL HAD ON THE REGION. FUNDED
AND TROUT FOUNDED OF. NEARLY
TWO FOUR OUR OF THE BY JOHN
AGAIN ARMY SHOULD ACCORDING A
DEATH TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
THE- THANK YOU CAN TO. ITS
OPPOSITE TO THE IN OF UNITED.
ON THE TWENTY. RANCH ANCIENT ON
TURKEY IN RECENT TO ACQUISITION
OF THE MALL BILLION DOLLAR
RUSSIAN MISSILE SYSTEMS THE
GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY CONTINUES
QUESTION IN THE AREA BY AND HAS
RECENTLY ATTACKED YOU WITH A
CRUISE I WITHIN THEIR OWN
TERRITORY BUT CONTINUE TO
VIOLATE HUMAN RIGHTS.
UNDERGROUND A CURTAILING AND
REGIME ASSEMBLY SILENCES. ANY
DOMESTIC OPPOSITION. DEPENDENT
JUDGES WITH THEM LITERALLY. AND
ACCORDING TO COMMITTEE TO PUT
OUR PROTECTORS TURKEY AROUND
ONLY BEHIND CHINA IN THE NUMBER
OF PRISONERS WE- SPOKE TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S STATE
TRUST MONEY FROM INVESTMENT IN
TURKEY WHILE SENDING A VERY
STRONG MESSAGE TO ANY COUNTRY
CODE TONIGHT YOU'RE NOTIFIED
AND WORKS AGAINST THE UNITED
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TO COMMITTEE
INTEREST BEING ONE OF THE GRANT
LARGEST GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS OF ARMENIAN
DESCENT IN THE UNITED STATES A
LARGE NUMBER OF OUR MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS ARE MAD OUR MEMBERS
ARE CALPERS AND ALSO BE.
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM WE
VALUE AND FULLY SUPPORT THE
INTEGRITY AND THE STABILITY OF
THE SPONSORED OUR RESEARCH
CLEARLY INDICATES THAT TURKEY
IS THE RESPONSIBLE ACTION IN
THE PAST HAS CREATED VOLATILITY
ECONOMIC MARKET IN TURKEY WHICH.
DOES NOT- I FOUND IN THAT AT A
SENATOR PER. VERY OF CAREER
POINT OUT THERE BEEN A- DAY. IN
IN- TRYING BY THE- OF TURKEY WE
THINK YOU AND AFTER YEARS OF IN
THE PASSAGE THE STATE. THANK
YOU I'M M. TO UNDER IS IN A-
LEAD SOME WHAT- IF YOU'RE- YOU
MAY I YOURSELF IMPROVE. YES
THIS IS ME ON TO MY HI GOOD
EVENING MR AND THEN MEMBERS I
SERVE AS THE WESTERN REGION
DIRECTOR OF THE ARMENIAN
ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA. A
NATIONWIDE NONPARTISAN
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
WHICH STRIVES TO RAISE GREATER
AWARENESS AND UNDERSTANDING OF
ARMENIAN ISSUES. ARE NEEDED
ASSEMBLY STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN AND SALUTE
CENTER PORTANTINO AND MINORITY
LEADER WILL FOR INTRODUCING IT.
SB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES TO
THE BOARDS OF ADMINISTRATION OF
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS TO
PROVIDE EMPLOYERS PARTICIPATING
IN THE SYSTEMS WHICH ARE
MUNICIPALITIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AN OPTION TO ELECT
INVESTMENT PORTFOLIOS NOT
CONTAINING INVESTMENT VEHICLES
ARE DEBT SECURITIES ISSUED OR
OWNED BY THE GOVERNMENT OF
TURKEY. TO BE CLEAR THE PURPOSE
OF THIS BEFORE FIFTY SEVEN IS
TO CRAFT A SENSIBLE POLICY
WHICH REFRAIN FROM FINANCIALLY
REWARDING INVESTING IN FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS SUCH AS THE
GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY WHICH
UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY TRAMPLE
UPON THE BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS OF
ITS OWN CITIZENS. AND ATTACK
NEIGHBORING OUNTRIES INCLUDING
ARMENIA AND ARTSAKH. HE'S
DOUBLE SPIN OF CHARACTERS IN
NINETEEN THIRTEEN AND CALPERS
IN NINETEEN THIRTY TWO
THOUSANDS OF ARMENIAN AMERICAN
RETIREES AS WELL AS CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED CIVIL SERVANTS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING EDUCATORS
ENGINEERS ECONOMISTS AT IS
LIBRARIANS AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THEIR AND
THEIR EMPLOYERS RESPECTED
CONTRIBUTIONS TO BUILD SYSTEMS.
ARMENIAN AMERICAN RETIREES AND
ACTIVELY EMPLOYED CIVIL
SERVANTS IN CALIFORNIA MAKE UP
A SIGNIFICANT CONSTITUENCY BUT
THE STORIED HISTORIES OF
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN. I TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO BRIEFLY SHARE THE STORIES OF
THE ARMENIAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE VESTED IN
EITHER CALPERS AND CAL STIRS IN
SUPPORT SP FOUR FIFTY SEVEN.
THE DAUGHTER OF ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE SURVIVORS HELEN HAIG
IS A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY OF AMERICA
SHE'S A DISTINGUISHED PUBLIC
SERVANT THE SERVANT SACRAMENTO
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR POLICY
DEVELOPMENT UNDER GOVERNOR
DEKMEJIAN. ALLEN'S MOTHER
ALICE IS A CHILD WITNESSED THE
MASSACRE OF MANY ADULTS
INCLUDING FAMILY MEMBERS IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE OTTOMAN
TURKISH. TOWN OF WAR FONG AND
BARELY ESCAPED THE ATROCITIES
OF WITH HER MY- I WOULD RECALL
THAT. ALISON FROM INTENSE FROM
NIGHTMARE ISSUE. THE HORRORS OF
OUR CHILD. TRADITION MANY-REASON TELL IN A- LOS ANGELES
READ WHO WAS. IN CALPERS WE
APPRECIATE THE PERKS OF IN CHIU
CAL. INVESTMENT CORP. AND
DIVEST FROM TURKISH GOVERNMENT
OWNED INVESTMENT VEHICLES HAS
INTENDED BY SP FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN. SECOND THE SON OF
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE SURVIVORS WHO
FOUND REFUGE IN JERUSALEM IN
THE IMMEDIATE POST GENOCIDE ERA
PROFESSOR- SHEEN BECAUSE SHE
SHE AND- IS A RETIRED
COUNSELOR. IN ARMENIAN LANGUAGE
INSTRUCTOR WHO WORKED AT
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
PROFESSION BECAUSE SHE'S GONNA
PROBABLY BUSTED INTEL STIRS IN
SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF SB FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN. WHICH FOR EXAMPLE
WOULD ALLOW FOR THE CITY OF
GLENDALE AND THE TWO U. S. THE-
CENTER PORTANTINO MENTION. HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO WORK WITH
CHARACTERS NEXT YEAR CLEAR OF
INVESTING IN TURKISH GOVERNMENT
ISSUED DEBT SECURITIES. FINALLY
I SHARE THE STORY OF RETIRED
EDUCATOR EDWARD MANASI IN
MORAGA CALIFORNIA WHO TAUGHT
HISTORY AND GOVERNMENT FOR
TWENTY NINE YEARS AT LANEY
COLLEGE IN OAKLAND. AND FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL THE SON OF
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE SURVIVORS MR
MINASSIAN WAS BORN IN THE
UNITED STATES. BUT LOST HIS
OLDER HALF BROTHER THREE YEAR
OLD HIKE DURING THE GENOCIDE MR
MINASSIAN IS THE AUTHOR OF A
NON FICTION BOOK TITLED LUCIDA
OR MOUNT MOTORS. WHICH
CHRONICLES THE DELETERIOUS
INTERVENTION. OF OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT THE US GOVERNMENT IN
THE NINETEEN THIRTIES IN THE
SUPPRESSION OF METRO GOLDWYN
MAYER'S. MOTION PICTURE
DEPICTING ARMENIANS. THE ROIC
DEFENSE OF THEIR PEOPLE. HI MOM
MOSES DURING THE GENOCIDE THE
PRODUCED TO BE DIRECTED BY THE
EMINENT TO MAKE RUBEN MY- WERE
BASED ON FRANCE FOES NOW. ON
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE TITLED
FORTY AT MOST AFTER. A PUSHED
TO TUNE. THE ROLE OF WARSAW
GHETTO RESISTANCE DURING THE
HOLOCAUST. MR MINASSIAN
SUPPORTS THE ADOPTION OF SB
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN. FOR THESE
REASONS THE ARMENIAN ASSEMBLY
OF AMERICA URGES YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN I THANK
EACH OF YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION. OKAY THANK YOU. WE
ARE NOW GOING TO COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM TO SEE IF
THERE'S SOMEONE. THERE ARE
WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO WISH TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL FIFTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN C. NINE. APPEAR A LOOK AT
YOUR FULL ROOM THERE WERE NO
WITNESSES. TO TESTIFY WILL GO
TO THE MODERATOR NOW AND ASK
YOU TO QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON HAS BEFORE FIFTY
SEVEN IF YOU COULD PLEASE
INDICATE THE NUMBER THAT YOU
HAVE WE APPRECIATE IT. REMINDER
THAT- WE HAVE TIME LIMITS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED-
ALSO. FOR THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS NURSE MODERATOR. AND-
STAFF TO LET US KNOW WHEN WE.
PREACH OF LIMITS IF THAT'S THE
CASE THANK YOU. IT HAS NINETY
ORDER. YEAR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO HAVE ANY-
IF YOU'RE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE MODERATOR WE DO ONE
REMINDED THE ONLY OPTING TO
SPEAK HERE HIS NAME
AFFILIATION. IN SUPPORT BECAUSE
RUN THE SUPPORT LINE NOW. THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN. IF THERE'S ANY
LINES IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE
NO WAITING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
WAS JUST A MOMENT TO ONE AS
SENATOR PORTANTINO I GOT A
MESSAGE THAT YOU MAY HAVE
WANTED TO. ASK A QUESTION OF
SOMEBODY ON THE TOTAL COVERAGE
LINES ARE CORRECT TO RECESSION
BUT IN A TELECONFERENCE LINE
THEY MAY NOT HAVE MADE IT HOME
IN TIME SO UNDERSTOOD I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THIRTY THIRD
TO OPPORTUNITY. WAS PRESENT
THAT WE AFFORD YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU- WE WILL
COME BACK NOW TO OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES EVER THE ONLY A LEAD
OPPOSITION JENNIFER BAKER- IN
IT APPEARS TO BE ALSO HAVE SIR
BRAMBLE- WE CAN TAKE IN ANY
ORDER PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
IN EITHER ONE OF YOU MAY
PROCEED- I'M GONNA ASK. OF
JENNIFER'S AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL.
THANK YOU I AM HONORED TO IF I
GO ON FIRST. YOU CAN GO FIRST
WITH JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
ORDER- IS THIS MR BRAMBLE. YES
YEAH PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND%
SENATORS MY NAME IS SETH
BRAMBLE I'M SPEAKING THIS
EVENING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
OUR MEMBERS WORK WITH SIX
MILLION STUDENTS AND ELEVEN
HUNDRED SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE FACING TEACHING
SHORTAGES THATPREDATE THE
PANDEMIC BUT HAVE WORSENED IN
MANY DISTRICTS SENTENCE
AMERICANS WE'RE SEEING A
SURGEON TEACHERS RETIRING
EARLIER THAN PLANNED IN MAJOR
PART. DUE TO THE CHALLENGES OF
TEACHING DURING THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THOMAS OF THE
SECURE RETIREMENT IS ONE OF THE
BENEFITS THAT DRIVES GOOD
CANDIDATES INTO THIS
PROFESSION. WELL LONG TERM
FUNDING PLANS ARE PUT IN PLACE
TO ADDRESS UNFUNDED LIABILITY
ANYTHING THAT LIMITS THE
ABILITY OF OUR PUBLIC PENSION
SYSTEMS TO ACHIEVE THEIR
INVESTMENT TARGET. COMPROMISES
THE PLAN THE MAJORITY OF OUR
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING CAL STIRS
AND ASSEMBLY BILLS- FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN ESTABLISH THE COASTERS
FUNDING PLAN. THIS PLAN PUTS
CALLUSES ON THE PATH TO FULL
FUNDING BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY FORTY SIX THROUGH
INCREMENTAL SHARE CONTRIBUTION
INCREASES AMONG THE PROGRAM'S
THREE CONTRIBUTORS CUSTER'S
MEMBERS EMPLOYERS. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE BEST MAN
CARRIES THE RISK OF ADVERSELY
AFFECTING THE INVESTMENT
PORTFOLIO THIS BILL IS
ESPECIALLY PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS AN INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYER TO CHOOSE TO DIVEST.
CREATING THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYERS ACROSS
THE STATE COULD SEE DIFFERENT
INVESTMENT RETURNS TO BE BLUNT
IT DEFEATS THE PURPOSE OF
HAVING A STATEWIDE PUBLIC
PENSION SYSTEM. THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY EMPLOYERS
AND MEMBERS MUST BE PUT
TOGETHER AND INVESTED JOINTLY
IN A SINGLE PORTFOLIO WITH
INVESTMENT RETURNS BEING
CREDITED TO THE SYSTEM RATHER
THAN INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYER
ACCOUNTS CAN YOU IMAGINE. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON
CASTERS TO ESTABLISH. THIS MANY
SEPARATE PORTFOLIOS CASTERS IS
WITH US THIS EVENING TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT TO BE CLEAR
THAT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION TO
TELL YOU THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. ONE ADMINISTRATION
ALONE WE OPPOSE SENATE BILL.
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU MISTER.
JENNIFER BIG YOU NEXT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR GOOD
EVENING- MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN
WITHIN THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JENNIFER BAKER AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
RETIRED TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
72% OF CHARACTERS MEMBERS ARE
WOMEN'S ISSUES THE IMPACT
CHARACTERS ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
WOMEN. RETIRED TEACHERS ARE
INCREASINGLY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY SOCIAL SECURITY
OFFSETS IN HOLES IN THE
MEDICARE COVERAGE LEAVING MANY
ECONOMICALLY VULNERABLE
PARTICULARLY IN TODAY'S ECONOMY
WHICH IS BEING COMPOUNDED BUT
BABY BOOMER RETIREMENTS. ARE
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE STEMS
NOT ONLY FROM THE YACHT
DESIGNERS THE OLD TIMIDLY AT
YOU GUYS ADMIT FROM TURKEY
WITHOUT INDEMNIFICATION TO THE
CHARACTER ON. THE COMPLETE
ERADICATION OF CHARACTERS
WITHIN HIGHER INVESTMENT
STRUCTURE SOLELY FOR ONE ISSUE.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY ANXIOUS ABOUT
THEIR RETIREMENT SECURITY AS
DISCUSSIONS LIKE THIS HAVE
TAKEN PLACE WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION TO THEIR LONG
TERM RETIREMENT SECURITY.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST DECADE THE
GREAT RECESSION AND INITIAL
PANDEMIC ECONOMY HAS WREAKED
HAVOC ON THE HEALTH. AND WELL
BEING OF RETIREES. HELLO THREE
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBER
YOU BIG HEAD COACH NINETEEN
THIRTY SEVEN A WHICH WERE OUT
MEMBERS AT. I DID WE HAVE
RECENTLY SEEN A 26% INCREASE IN
TEACHERS RETIREMENT THIS PAST
YEAR WHICH MAY CREATE
ADDITIONAL FISCAL LONG TERM
STRAIN ON THE OVERALL HEALTH OF
THE SECTOR. OUR MEMBERSHIP
FAILED TO UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
SHOULD BE HELD. ACCOUNTABLE
DECISION THAT SHOULD BE BORNE
BY THE STATE THEY CERTAINLY
DON'T SUPPORT THE ACTIONS OF
THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT BUT WITH
THE WEALTHIEST AMERICANS VIçT
BECOMING EVEN MORE WEALTHY WHY
IS IT THAT MIDDLE CLASS WOMEN
NOT THAT YOU PERCENT FOR
CORPORATE AMERICA ARE SEEN AS
THE PRIMARY CLASS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE RETIREMENT
SECURITY SHOULD BE PART. IN BED
OF ALL TAXPAYERS. PAYING FOR
THE COST OF THE MEASURE. MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE MEASURE COMPLY
REDO THE INVESTMENT BRANCH OF.
WHICH ELIMINATE THE ABILITY OF
CHARACTER STAFF TO REACH
INVESTMENT GOALS WHICH WOULD
HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON STATE
SCHOOL AND TEACHER CONTRIBUTION
RATES AND I'M SURE YOU'VE ALL
BEEN CARING FOR THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN YOUR AREA.
REGARDING CONCERNS ABOUT
INCREASED OFF PROBABLY
INTENTIONS. TO REVIEW. I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO FIT RAPPA PLEASE.
I'M SORRY WE HAVE A TEN MINUTE
WAIT STRAIGHT. PRODUCT MANAGER
THIS- WOULD BE DRASTIC PER
CHARACTERS WE ASKED YOU TO
SUPPORT THE RETIREMENT OF
SECURITY RETIRED TEACHERS BY
BUILDING NOW ON AT THE WORK
THAT COULD HAPPEN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COOPERATION- WE HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO JUST TRY TO BE
FAIR WITH THE TIME AS WE SPREAD
IT OUT AMONG OPPOSITION SUPPORT
AND SO FORTH AS YOU I'M SURE
FULLY UNDERSTAND SO- AGAIN
THANK YOU- WE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANY OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISH TO
SPEAK THE SCENE NONE. OF WE
WILL LOOK TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM
OF THEIR NO WITNESSES THERE TO
SPEAK I WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR NASA MODERATOR TO
QUEUE UP FOR ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES TO US BEFORE FIFTY
SEVEN. AND WHEN YOU DO WOULD
YOU PLEASE LET US KNOW HOW MANY
THERE ARE. IT IS VERY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AT THIS
TIME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE THREE LINES IN Q. WILL
FIRST GO TO LINE. LINES SEVENTY
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY BELMONT ON
THE OTHER COUNT MANY
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION. WE
WILL GO NEXT TO LINE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
ONE SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE
YES. I AM I AM ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS I AM I
APOLOGIZE I HAVEN'T DONE THIS
BEFORE AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
QUEUE UP I HAD BEEN WAITING MY
NAME IS- RT BECAUSE SOCKING ON
THE GLENDALE CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT BOIL THAT
RESPECTS THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF
OUR SYSTEM ARMENIAN- THIS IS
THIS THIS IS ONLY NAME. A
POSITION OR AFFILIATION IN
SUPPORTER POSE AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY ON THE OPPOSE NOW SO
WE'VE ALREADY HEARD THAT YOUR
SUPPORT OF I WAS THE PERSON I
WAS GONNA ASK A QUESTION TO HE
GOT ON LATE OR HE WAS CALLED ON
LIKE TO. ASK FOR CLARIFICATION.
HELLO ME. HE VIEW INTERPOSER
QUESTION TO THIS WITNESS. BUT
LET ME ASK THE MODERATOR OF
THEIR MORE OPPOSED WITNESSES IN
THE QUEUE FIRST. INTERNET THEN
PERHAPS WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY
COME BACK. THE MODERATOR. YES
SIR WE HAVE ONE LINE THAT IS
THANK YOU FOR OPPOSITION. BUT
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE OUTLINED
IN- EXHAUST THE QUEUE AND THEN
WE'LL COME BACK IN. FIVE IT
WITH THE ISSUE OF THE QUESTION
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU IN OUR
NEXT SLIDE OUR NEXT- WILL BE
FROM NINE THIRTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS HISTORICAL AND MARTINEZ
AWAY FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE WAS THE MODERATOR
OTHER THAN THE SEPT SECOND- LOS
TO THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES
INTO THIS TIME. THANK YOU- AS
AS A COURTESY- UNDERSTANDING
THAT TO SOMETHING HAPPENED WITH
THE- HI THE SUPPORT WITNESS
AND- WE WERE INSTRUCTED AT A
TIME THAT YOU HAD A QUESTION
FOR THE SPORT WITNESS. BUT
SENATOR YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR QUESTION HOPEFULLY THE
MODERATOR CAN FACILITATE A
RESPONSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR YOU'VE BEEN VERY GRACIOUS
AND I REALLY APPRECIATED TO
COUNCILMEMBER KASATKINA IS THE
ONE WHO SUGGESTED THIS
LEGISLATION TO ME AS A- PERSON
IN THE PER SYSTEM AND ALSO
DISSENTED OF. ARMENIAN GENOCIDE
SURVIVORS I JUST WANTED TO ASK
HIM. IF HE WOULD APPROXIMATE
ABOUT HOW MANY CITY AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES. ARE OF
ARMENIAN HERITAGE TO PAY INTO
THE SYSTEM. AND IF YOU COULD
JUST SHARE THAT WITH THE
COMMITTEE I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT INFORMATION JUST TO
PUT A PERSPECTIVE ON IT. IF IS
THERE. THE WOULD BE BELOW ABOVE
THREE FREE SPONSORED ON VERY
BRIEF PLEASE IF YOU'RE STILL
AVAILABLE SIR IT IS A- AND IF
HE'S NOT THERE I'LL JUST GO TO
MY CLOTHES WHEN APPROPRIATE
OKAY THANK YOU. WE'VE BEENVERY
GRACIOUS WE CAN MOVE O THE
ROAD ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO
AND MOVE ON- WHICH IS PROBABLY
MORE. IN LINE WITH OUR- RULES
OF ENGAGEMENT HERE IN TERMS OF
SPEAKERS AND WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME CENTER ALERT IS SB
KNOWLEDGE. THANK YOU- I THINK
THERE ARE TWO PARTS OF THIS
BILL AND ONE BILL IS THE PART
THAT HAS TO DO WITH HUMAN
RIGHTS. WHERE THE CASE HAS BEEN
VERY COMPELLINGLY MADE. THE
SECOND PART IS HOW IF THERE IS.
AN ECONOMIC ISSUE HOW IT'S
DRIVEN HOME I THINK THAT PART
IS FLAWED. I THINK IT NEEDS
WORK AND I DON'T WANT THE- THE
NOTION THAT THAT MIGHT BE
FLAWED TO STOP THE BILL AND
HAVE ANYBODY INTERPRETED IT. AS
OUR STATEMENT ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THAT PART OF THE
WORLD AND SO WHAT I WOULD
SUGGEST IS. IS THAT WE MOVE
THIS BONE BUT WE LET THE AUTHOR
KNOW HE'S GOT SOME WORK TO DO
ON THE SIDE THAT'S THE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM TO FIX. AND
THEN I WOULD HOPE. IF WE SEE
THIS ON THE FLOOR WHO OVER
ANOTHER TIME THAT THOSE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED BUT- THE
AUTHOR HAS MADE A COMPELLING
CASE AND I WANT TO GIVE THEM A
CHANCE TO. TO ALIGN THE IMPACT
OF THE BILL WITH THE GRAVITY OF
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO ADDRESS
SO DO PROPER TIME I'LL BE
WILLING TO MOVE THE BILL AND
THAT WOULD BE MY UNDERSTANDING.
WITH REGARD TO IT BEING ABLE.
THE HE'LL BE JUST THAT I. SHE
THAT ALMOST FEEL LIKE YOU. WE
SHARED A SPEECH OF FOR TODAY'S-
DISCUSSION NONPARTISAN WHICH OF
COURSE WE BOTH KNOW WE DID NOT-
IT OUT I'D ACTUALLY EVEN GO A
LITTLE BIT JUST A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER AND IT JUST SAY- THAT I
ACTUALLY THINK. THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY BEYOND THESE FIVE
SENATORS ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
A ROBUST DEBATE ON ON BOTH
SIDES THERE'S IS A PART OF ME
THAT WANTS TO SEE THIS. OUT OF
IT INTO THE LARGER FORUM BOTH
OF THE HUMAN RIGHTS SIDE- AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT OPPORTUNITY
IS. AVAILABLE THUS FAR BUT BUT
ALSO IN THIS ISSUE ON THIS
ISSUE OF SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
AND AT WHAT POINT DOES HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATION RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF MORE WE ACTUALLY. TAKE
THIS KIND OF A OF AN ACTION- I
AM NOT SOLD ON THAT YET BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW THE IMPLICATIONS
AND- I DID HAVE A DISCUSSION
WITH THE AUTHOR AHEAD OF TIME
AND INDICATED THAT. RELEASED
I'D PROBABLY USE THAT WORD ONCE
OR TWICE TODAY BUT AS A
COURTESY- TO THE OTHER MEMBERS
WHO MAY WHO MAY WISH TO WEIGH
IN ON THIS ISSUE TO THE TO THE
AUTHOR- WHO. I IS ALL. ARE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING GOOD IN
TERMS OF HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE. OF
BUT TO. ADVANCE THE BILL AS
CENTER ALERT SAID. REALLY
AREN'T TOO TO ALLOW THE DEBATE
THE BROADER DEBATE THE CURSED
BE ON THIS COMMITTEE ROOM- BUT
IT BUT I MUST SAY YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF THINGS LIKE HELP. THE
MORE GRANULAR ISSUES LIKE HOW
DO YOU INDEMNIFY- THE COASTERS
YOU KNOW BROUGHT UP BY THE
OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF. THE
HARD WORK THEY WERE DOING TO
TRY TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES
AROUND UNFUNDED. PENSIONS AND
SO FORTH HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU TAKE A SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY ACTION AT THE
SAME TIME- NOT YOU KNOW UNDER
CUT THE GOOD WORK THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO. A DESPITE THE
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUE SO I THINK THOSE
ISSUES REALLY NEED- THE NEW
THROUGH DEBATE WHICH IS REASON
TO GET THEM OUT- BUT THEY ALSO
PREFER THIS VOTE ON. ON A GOING
FORWARD BASIS YOU KNOW RAISE
SOME ADDITIONAL CONCERNS- AND
CERTAINLY CENTER PORTANTINO
WHEN WE'RE DONE UP HERE- IF YOU
WANT INCLUDES ANYTHING ABOUT-
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS
ABOUT. THE UNDERCUTTING OF THE
SYSTEM OF FROM A FINANCIAL
STANDPOINT I THINK OF ALL THIS
WOULD BE OPEN TO HEARING THAT
ALTHOUGH YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
DO THAT IS YOU KNOW- SENATORS
ANYONE ELSE WISH TO COMMENT
CENTER NEWMAN. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER SURE SO. THAT NONE I
WANT TO SAY. AND VERY
RESPECTFULLY SAY THAT I HAVE.
GREAT SYMPATHY FOR THE GOALS OF
THE BILL SENATE- I AM EQUALLY
SYMPATHETIC TO BE. THE
COMPLAINT. OF THE RETIREES THAT
IT IS THEY WHO WOULD BE
ABSORBING THE BURDEN- AND NOT
THE STATE- AND SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO MAKE A
DISTINCTION. BETWEEN OUR
INVESTMENT POLICIES MOVING
FORWARD- THAT SHOULD RIGHTFULLY
BE BASED ON IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLES SUCH AS THIS. AND
THEN THAT DIFFERENT QUESTION
HOW WE DIVEST. OF SOME OF THESE
ASSETS WHILE HOLDING HARMLESS
THE BENEFICIARIES OF THOSE
RETIREMENT MONIES- AND SO ON
FORCING WHILE I DO AGAINST
SYMPATHIZED WITH YOUR GOALS
HERE AND CERTAINLY WITH. THE
SENTIMENTS OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. I WILL
UNFORTUNATELY VOTING NO TODAY.
SUBMITTER SAID RUSSELL YES- THE
LITTLE ARMENIAN COMMUNITY WHICH
IS THE HISTORIC HOME OF
ARMENIANS IN THE STATE AND
PROBABLY IN THE COUNTRY IS IN
MY DISTRICT- THOSE MEN WOMEN
FAMILIES HAVE SHARED WITH ME
FOR YEARS WHAT IT IS THAT THEY
HAVE SUFFERED WITH IT IS THAT
THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH SO I
FEEL- THEIR STORY HAS GOT IS
STARTING TO GET OUT. IN A
SIGNIFICANT WAY THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD AND I COMMEND THE
ARMENIAN COMMUNITY FOR FIGHTING
BACK OF WITH WHAT HAS TAKEN
PLACE. IN THEIR COMMUNITY WITH
THE- IN AT WITH THE GENOCIDE SO
I SUPPORT AS BEFORE FIFTY SEVEN.
I UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL
ISSUES OF FACING- THE
RETIREMENT FUND I WAS A TRUSTEE
ON A RETIREMENT FUND FOR MANY
YEARS- AND WE HAD TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO REFLECT THE VALUES
OF OUR STATE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT%
IT- WHAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
WORKED ON I AGREE WITH SENATOR
LAYERED AND MY OTHER COLLEAGUES
THAT THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE YOU
KNOW. YES OR NO THIS IS THIS
HAS SOME REAL IMPLICATIONS
WHICH IS PARTLY THE REASON THAT
HAVE COME BEFORE US BECAUSE IT
HAS IT SHOULD HAVE IMPLICATIONS
FOR TURKEY FOR WHAT THEY FAILED
TO RECOGNIZE AND WHAT THEY
FAILED TO DO SO- IT IS
UNCOMFORTABLE IT IS A VERY
DIFFICULT DECISION. I THINK
THERE'S A WAY OF MOVING FORWARD
TO GET THE MESSAGE ACROSS TO
TURKEY- AND- AND NOT HURT THE
RETIREES NOW WE ALL KNOW THAT
BY TAKING. ONE OPTION OUT. OF
PICTURE DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE
WHOLE RETIREMENT FUND IS GOING
TO GO DOWN THE TUBES- WE'LL
HAVE TO THE- RETIREMENT BOARD
WILL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW HOW
TO WORK THAT OUT BUT- IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT. THEY WILL
AUTOMATICALLY LOSE THEIR OTHER
INVESTMENT OPTIONS AND AGAIN
MAYBE I'M MAKING THIS TOO
SIMPLE I'M SURE PEOPLE WOULD
SAY. BUT I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT- THAT. AND MAYBE SOME
PEOPLE ARE WHO OPPOSE THIS ARE
THINKING THIS IS DOWN A
SLIPPERY SLOPE WE DO THIS ON
THIS ISSUE OF THE GENOCIDE OF
ARMENIAN PEOPLE MAYBE WILL
START PICKING UP OTHER ISSUES I
UNDERSTAND THAT COULD POSSIBLY
COME UP. BUT I DON'T THINK THAT
WE SHOULD BOMB. NOT TAKE A STEP
FORWARD- IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BECAUSE OF OTHER UP BECAUSE OF
LEGITIMATE LEGITIMATE OTHER
CONCERNS I UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
RETIREES ARE COMING FROM I
DON'T WANT. ANYONE TO MESS WITH
MY RETIREMENT THAT'S FOR SURE
BUT- THIS IS A RESPONSIBILITY
THAT WE HAVE WHICH IS. NOT ONLY
INCLUDE THE INTEREST OF THE
RETIREES BUT OF OTHER PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THE
SENATOR WHO KNOWS MORE ABOUT
YOUR- I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO
AFINITOR LEYRITZ COMMENTS-
BECAUSE HERS I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT I YOU PERFECTLY IN VERY
ELOQUENTLY- PLEADED DIFFERENCES
CEDED TO CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
HERE- AND IT IS I DO HAVE- I
WOULD. VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR CENTER
PORTANTINO TO ADDRESS A
POSSIBLE THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT UP FROM THE
OPPOSITION WITH REGARDS TO THE-
I GUESS WOULD BE THE
LOGISTICAL. ISSUES OF THE BILL
BECAUSE IN MERIT I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND AND SUPPORT. YOUR
POSITION YEAH. I'M JUST KIND OF
CURIOUS TO SEE IF HE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS. THE CONCERNS THE
LOGISTICAL PART- I PERSONALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT IT
ALLOWS FOR- I APPRECIATE THE
FACT IT DOES ALLOW FOR THAT.
THE EMPLOYERS TO CHOOSE AN
INVESTMENT OPTION I I'M ALWAYS
ABOUT HAVING OPTIONS AND
CHOICES FOR CONSUMERS AND
PEOPLE ARE ON THAT ENDEAVOR BUT
I CAN UNDERSTAND THE COST
BEHIND THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS AT THIS TIME
ABSOLUTELY MISTER CHAIR BACK
ADDRESS ALL OF THE QUESTIONS
DURING MY CLOTHES THAT PROBABLY
IS THE BEST WAY TO DO IT IF YOU
WANT OR DO YOU WANT ME TO
ADDRESS I THINK IT'S- I THINK
IT'S A GOOD. ORDER GIVEN THAT
EVERYONE IN THE DANCE IS NOW
SPOKEN AND- FIVE. YOU COULD
JUST FOLD INTO YOUR CLOTHES
RESPONSES TO- OUR BY CHAIR A
RIDE SHARES OVER A QUESTION
THERE- THAT WOULD BE GREAT AND
THEN LET ME I DON'T WANT TO.
TAKE YOU OFF BEFORE IF YOU'RE
NOT READY FOR HIM TO GO TO HIS
CLOTHES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT'S ABOUT THE ONLY A CONCERN
OPPORTUNITY THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THE TOURIST OKAY SO A
USER BY SEARS. SEATING FOR NOW
AND- WE COME BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR CLOTHES AN ASSET YOU. PUT
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE RESPOND TO
THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MEMBERS YOUR
COM. I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IN
THE NOW- NUMBER FOUR. UNDER
EXISTING LAW. IT POINTS OUT
THAT- CALPERS AND CAL STIRS ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS FOR A RUN.
PURSUE DONE AND FOR BUSINESSES
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST ISRAEL
RELATED TO THE ARAB BOYCOTT.
AND ALSO FOR THERMAL COAL
COMPANY SO THIS IS NOT
PRECEDENT SETTING. THE
ACCOUNTING INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE. SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO WHEN THE ARMENIAN
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WENT TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. AND SAID
WE'D LIKE YOU TO DIVEST FROM
TURKEY WITH YOUR INVESTMENTS.
DIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAID YES.
AND DID IT SO. WE HAVE ONE OF
THE LARGEST INSTITUTIONS IN
CALIFORNIA THE UC I WAS ABLE TO
DO IT. WE HAVE BOTH OF THESE
TWO INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO IT ONE TWO THREE
FOUR TIMES ALREADY. SO TO SAY
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE-
ACCOUNTING CAPABILITY TO DO IT.
FRANKLY I FIND THAT. TO BE A
SUSPECT ARGUMENT I UNDERSTAND
IT'S SOMETHING THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO- BUT THEY'VE DONE IT IN
THE PAST AND- TWO YEARS AGO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. I
INSTITUTED A POLICY TO DO IT
PROSPECTIVELY AS WELL NUMBER
TWO. THE AND I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE SENATOR FROM LOS
ANGELES. THIS THE SUPPOSITION
THAT THIS GUY IS GOING TO FALL.
IF THEY DO THIS I THINK IT IS
NOT NECESSARILY AN ACCURATE
DEPICTION OF THEIR PROWESS IN
MANAGING THE RETIREE'S
PORTFOLIO AND THE PERCENTAGE OF
THAT PORTFOLIO THAT'S INVESTED
IN TURKEY RELATIVE TO THE REST
OF IT AS I SAID IN THE
BEGINNING 70% OF THEIR
INVESTMENTS ARE U. S. SO WE
ALREADY START OUT WITH A
SEVENTY PERCENT. POOL SO THE
PERCENTAGE OF THE OVERALL
PORTFOLIO IS NOT SIGNIFICANT
WHERE THIS DIVESTMENT IS GOING
TO AFFECT THE RETIREMENT OF ANY
OF THESE EMPLOYEES NOR DO I
THINK THE 30% OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT EMPLOYEES ARE 30% OF
THE CITY EMPLOYEES IN GLENDALE.
WOULD WANT THEIR RETIREMENT TO
BE SUSPECT SO I JUST THINK
THAT- POSTULATE IS HERE TO
ALARM YOU TO DRY YOUR
OPPOSITION TRADITIONALLY DIVEST
MEANT BILLS GET OPPOSED BY ALL
OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSING
THIS ONE. I'M SENSITIVE TO THAT
BUT I ALSO BELIEVE AS BEEN
ARTICULATED BY ALL OF YOU THE
SOCIAL INJUSTICE ASPECT OF IT
WE ARE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE WE BELIEVE IN A
CERTAIN SET OF VALUES. WE
BELIEVE IN HUMAN RIGHTS- WE
BELIEVE IN HUMAN RIGHTS AND WE
OPPOSE HUMAN RIGHTS INJUSTICES
AND INDIGNITIES THAT'S WHO WE
ARE AS A PEOPLE. AND TO TRY TO
PUT A PRICE ON THAT. AND TO TRY
TO ALARM YOU INTO THINKING THAT
THIS IMPLEMENTATION IS GREATER
THAN IT IS AND THE ACCOUNTING
PROBLEM IS A GREATER ACCOUNTING
PROBLEM THEN REALITY WHEN
THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH PRECEDENT
THAT HAVE ACCOMPLISHED THIS
GOAL WITH OTHER COUNTRIES- I
JUST THINK THAT'S MORE OF A
TACTIC. THAN A- TRUE ACCOUNTING
PROBLEM THAT CAN'T BE SOLVED
THEIR IMPLEMENTED I WILL TAKE
YOUR COMMENTS TO HEART. I AM
CAUGHT HAVING ALMOST WEEKLY
CONVERSATIONS WITH PERSON
STARES I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT BUT I AM EXTREMELY
PASSIONATE. ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL
TO DIVEST FROM TURKEY AND WE
CAN DO IT FOR A RON AND TO DON
AN ON CALL COMPANIES WE CAN
RESPECT THE OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ARMENIAN AMERICANS.
WHO LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY YOU
HAVE TO GO TO WORK EVERY DAY
AND KNOW THAT THOSE RESPONSIBLE
FOR KILLING THEIR ANCESTORS
WILL NOT OWN U TO THAT
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR KILLING THEIR
ANCESTORS HAVE INVADED A PART
OF THEIR COUNTRY HAVE KILLED
PEOPLE THAT I HAVE ACTUALLY
BROKEN BREAD WITH. AND OF
DESECRATED THE CHURCH THAT I
WENT TO A WEDDING AT. AND PROUD
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS OF GENOCIDE AND THAT'S
WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY AND I WILL LAST WORD
AS THIS BILL PROGRESSES.
PROGRESSES THROUGH THE SYSTEM
AND I WILL HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES AND SENATOR WILL
IS MY JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS AS
WELL AS ANOTHER NUMBER OF OTHER
AUTHORS. WANT TO GET OUT OF
THERE AS WELL. RIGHT SENATOR
THANK YOU- THANK YOU FOR THAT
WILL COME- BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR A MOTION. HIS
CEREMONY. ON THE BILL THE MOVED
MOVED- BY. OUR VICE CHAIR
SOONER- CHEWABLE. AND WE CAN
MOVE TO A ROLL CALL VOTE AT
THIS TIME LOS CONSULTANT TO
PROCEED WITH A- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
AND- LYFT. SENATOR CORTEZ THE
HI SENATOR- CHOKE HI HELLO CHAU
BOGUE BY SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR
DORADO AYE SENATOR LAYERED BY
BENDER LAYERED ARE SENATOR
NEWTON. NO SENATOR NEWMAN NOW.
OKAY YOU HAVE TO THE BILL'S OUT
ON AFFORDABLE VOTE THANK YOU-
IT JUST BEFORE- BY PASS THE
GAVEL BACK TO REPLACE YOUR ONE
MORE TIME BECAUSE MY BILL IS
THE LAST ONE NOW IN ORDER-
COMMITTEE RULES OR I WILL NOT
PRESIDE. OVER FINAL BILL-
BEFORE WE DO- CAN WE DO IF THE
CALL AT THIS TIME. I DO. I'M
NOT CLEAR. WHAT WE HAVE FLOW
LEFT ON ON THE CALL BUT IN
TERMS OF CALLING ON ABSENT
MEMBERS ALWAYS CONSUME DO THAT
NOW. OPEN IN THE ROLE AND SB
SEVEN TWO SEVEN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REPEAL RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR CORTEZ A FIVE. AND A
CORTES THE I. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE- THAT THE SUBJECT
MATTER. OKAY SO THE BILL IS NOW
OUT ON A FOUR TO ONE VOTE.
THANK YOU. I WILL NO ACOSTA
GAVEL OVER TO- COMMITTEE VICE
SURE. HE SAID. THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL AND SB. FOUR ELEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- SENATORS-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NUMBER
PLEASE TO PRESENT S. B. FOR
ELEVEN THE WORK AFTER
RETIREMENT ACT. OF S. B. FOUR
ONE ONE WILL FALL CALPERS STAFF
TO WORK WITH RETIRED MEMBERS
EMPLOYERS TO RESOLVE WORKING
AFTER RETIREMENT VIOLATIONS
INEFFICIENT AND AGREEABLE
MANNER EXISTING LAWS CALPERS
RETIREE TO RETURN TO WORK WITH
THE CALPERS EMPLOYER UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS. THESE
RETIREES ARE ALSO KNOWN AS A
RETIRED ANNUITANT AND THEY ARE
LIMITED TO NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY HOURS OF WORK PER YEAR
THIS BILL WOULD NOT CHANGE
THAT. SOME RETIREES DO THIS TO
SUPPLEMENT THE RETIREMENT
INCOME ALL OTHERS BILLION
ESSENTIAL BECAUSE HE'S DURING
AN EMERGENCY TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
STAFFING OR ME TEMPORARILY
STAFF BEACON POSITIONS WHEN
NEEDED UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF
THESE RETIREES ARE HAVING TO
PAY SIGNIFICANT COSTS. TO RUN
INTENTIONALLY GOING OVER THEIR
CURRENT LIMITATION OF NINE AND
SIXTY HOURS FOR INSTANCE BUT
THEY WEREN'T AWARE OF THIS
LIMITATION WITH EMPLOYER MAY
HAVE INADVERTENTLY MIS INFORMED
THEM. IN APRIL TWENTY NINETEEN
CALPERS COMPLETED AN AUDIT OF
SIXTY ONE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
INDICATED A 52% OF THOSE
AGENCIES AUDITED FOR VIOLATION
OF THE NINERS SIXTY OUR ROLE IN
39% DID NOT REPORT. HOURS
WORKED AS REQUIRED. YES OF FOUR
ELEVEN WITH SOME GRANT THE
BOARD THE OF THE TO REACH A
FAIR RESOLUTION WITH RETIREES
WINTER PEARLY GLOW OVER THE
NINERS SIXTY HOUR LIMIT. BASED
ON THE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CONDITIONS OF THAT PARTICULAR
VIOLATIONS WITHOUT HAVING TO
FORCE RETIRED RETIREE TO
REINSTATE BACK INTO THE SYSTEM.
THIS WILL PUT AN END TO WHAT IN
SOME CASES CAN AMOUNT TO THE
EGREGIOUS ENCUMBRANCE ON
RETIREES AND INSTEAD ALLOW FOR
MORE SWIFT AND EFFECTIVE
RESOLUTIONS TO THESE
UNINTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS. ARE
RETIREES DESERVE RESPECT PEACE
OF MIND AND A SENSE OF SECURITY
FOR THE FUTURE. AS A CONTINUE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR STATE
SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC AGENCIES
ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME. OF
SUCH SOCIAL ECONOMIC TURMOIL.
WITH US TODAY IS- DAVID SHAPIRO
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. AND BELINDA JOHNSON
WHO WILL BE PROVIDING A
PERSONAL TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF
HER MOTHER FORMER RETIREE ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU AND THIRTY PER TIME OF
COURSE WILL BE ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
PORTES HE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THEM OUR LEAD WITNESS SWITCHES
MISTER DAVIS APPEARING HERE'S
HERE IN PERSON. THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIRMAN MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- MY
NAME IS DAVE SPIRAL I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
CSE IS THE SPONSOR OF SB FOUR
ELEVEN BECAUSE THE BILL
REPRESENTS A MOVE TOWARD
FAIRNESS FOR RETIREES. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM KNOWN AS
CALPERS. AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES PENSION REFORM
ACT NOTICE PREPARA ALLOWS
RETIREES TO WORK FOR A PUBLIC
EMPLOYER AFTER RETIREMENT AS
LONG AS THEY WAIT AT LEAST A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS AFTER
RETURNING TO WORK- BEFORE
RETURNING TO WORK. AND WORK NO
MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY HOURS PER FISCAL YEAR. IT
RETIREES EXCEED THE NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY HOUR LIMIT
UNDER CURRENT LAW. CALPERS IS
TECHNICALLY FORCED TO REINSTATE
THEM AS ACTIVE MEMBERS. THE
PERSON WHO IS DEDICATED YEARS
IN THE CASE OF CSEA MEMBERS TO
STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM.
IS THEN REQUIRED TO PAY BACK
ALL THEIR EARNED RETIREE
BENEFITS THEY RECEIVED AFTER
EXCEEDING THE HOUR LIMIT BY
EVEN JUST ONE HOUR. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE RULES
THAT RETIREES MUST FOLLOW. BUT
THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
PUNISHMENT HERE OFTEN DOES NOT
FIT THE CRIME. CSEA RETIREES
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO PAY BACK SIX
FIGURES OF THEIR HARD EARNED
RETIREE BENEFITS BECAUSE THEY
WERE MISINFORMED OR MISLED BY
THEIR EMPLOYERS. PEOPLE LIVING
ON A FIXED INCOME WHO COUNT ON
THE PENSION THEY'VE EARNED HAVE
FACED MORTGAGING THEIR HOMES
BECAUSE PUBLIC EMPLOYERS WHO
OFTEN BACK OUR RETIREES TO COME
BACK TO FILL A CRITICAL NEED.
THEN FAILED TO PROMPTLY REPORT
THEIR HOURS TO CALPERS AND
NOTIFY THE RETIREE THAT THEY
CROSSED THE NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY OUR THRESHOLD. SB FOUR
ELEVEN WOULD GIVE CALPERS THE
ABILITY TO CONSIDER THESE SORTS
OF MITIGATING FACTORS IN
DETERMINING WHETHER RETIREE
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE REINSTATED
THAT HAVE TO PAY BACK THE
EARNED BENEFITS OVER. IF THERE
IS A MORE REASONABLE SOLUTION
FOR RETIREE WHO HAS EXCEEDED
THE CAP CONSIDERING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF EACH CASE. TO
GIVE CALPERS THAT LIMITED
DISCRETION. TO CONSIDER THE NEW
WANTS AND FAIRNESS IN EACH
CASE. CSEA RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE HONEST BEFORE
ELEVEN AM THANKS GERMAN CORTESE
FOR AUTHORING THE BILL. AND
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SUPPLIER. AND I PRONOUNCE IT
CORRECTLY THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE
A SECOND LEAD WITNESS BELINDA
JOHNSON. ARE YOU ON THE LINE
MISTER JOHNSON. YES I AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE PROCEED
MA'AM. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LINDA JOHNSON AND MY
MOTHER CUANDO HARDY BY THE CAAC
AND MEMBER AND CALPERS RETIREES
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE SHE
RETIRED FROM HER POSITION AS A
NATION IT INSTRUCTIONAL AIDE
FROM ON TERROR AMONG. MISSION
AFTER MOM RETIRED THE DISTRICT
AFTER TO SUBSTITUTE BECAUSE OF
A SHORTAGE OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
PARA PROFESSIONAL WHY SHE
WORKED AS A SUBSTITUTE I HELPED
HER CREATE A SYSTEM FOR
TRACKING HER HOURS SO SHE WOULD
NOT EXCEED NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY HOURS PER YEAR SHE ALSO
COMMUNICATED THE LIMITATIONS OF
HER EMPLOYER EACH TIME THEY
CONTACTED HER WITH AND- FIND
IT. DIFFICULT ISSUE PRESSURED
HER SHE WOULD NOT EXCEED THE
HOURS OF THE TIME I WASN'T
AWARE MY MOTHER WAS IN THE
EARLY STAGES OF DEMENTIA AND
WAS UNABLE TO GIVE AN ACCURATE
COUNT ON HER OF HER HOURS. AND
DESPITE WHAT HER EMPLOYER SHE
SAID THEY WERE NOT TRACKING HER
OUR TO KEEP URBAN LOW NINE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN SHE BEGAN GETTING LOST
AND ROUTE THE SCHOOL SHE HAD
BEEN DRIVING TO THROUGHOUT HER
CAREER AND CONSEQUENTLY WAS NOT
ABLE TO CONTINUE WORKING.
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER SHE WAS
FORMALLY. WITH DEMENTIA AND WAS.
EVENTUALLY PLACED IN A NURSING
HOME. FIVE YEARS LATER IN TWO I
ISSUE A FROM HER STATING SHE-
THIRTY THOUGHT DOLLAR FOR BY.
THE NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY OUR
RULES. ARE RETIRED INCOME
WASN'T ENOUGH TO COVER THE COST
ARENA HOME AND I HAD PLENTY.
REFINANCING MY HOME OF RECORD
THAT. YEAH MY MOTHER AND IN
EXCESS OF THE NINE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY HOUR LIMIT WAS UNDER
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS OVER THE
COURSE OF FOUR YEARS. THE
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WHAT'S
YOUR ENTIRE RETIREMENT INCOME
EARNED OVER. THE YEARS SHE WAS
IN VIOLATION. S. FOUR ELEVEN
ALLOW PROGRAMMERS WHO WATCHES
RETIREES TO RESOLVE ISSUES IN
SIMILAR SITUATIONS LIKE MY
MOTHER. MY MOTHER SITUATION WAS
NO FAULT OF HER OWN. PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL COULD PREVENT
THIS UNFORTUNATE SITUATION FROM
HAPPENING OTHER RETIREE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MA'AM FOR SPEAKING
TODAY NOW WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. FOR ELEVEN HERE IN OUR IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE. DO WE HAVE
ANY C. NINE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR ELEVEN C. NINE.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE THE TWO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR THIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
ELEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
INTERFERE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. BY THIS MEASURE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
AT THIS TIME. GO FIRST ONLINE.
SEVENTY FIVE NINE SEVENTY FIVE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE OPEN
LINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
EVENING- SENATORS RAMBLE
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. TO
MOVE NEXT TO THE LINE SEVENTY
THREE. AND IS OPEN. OUR MEMBERS
HAVE BUDGET OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THE MOVE TO LINE SIXTY TWO
GO AHEAD PLEASE. THANK CHAIR
MEMBERS DILLON GIBBONS
REPRESENTING THE EMPLOYERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE ONE MORE LINE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. FIND SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT DO YOU
LIKE SEVENTY TWO YEAR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE- AND WE
ARE LOCATED LA EVER THE OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINES
ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORT WITNESSES FOR S. B.
FOUR ELEVEN. BETTER ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT BUT
WITNESSES PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. TO LINE SEVENTY
TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. YOU CAN
MEMBERS PAMPERING WITH THE
RETIRED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE NO OTHER LINES
INTO IT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. AND I BELIEVE WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- LET'S MOVE ON TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR ELEVEN HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION UP SB FOUR
ELEVEN. SEEING NONE. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE THIS
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AS
PEOPLE REALLY. LIVE IN AND WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BEFORE ELEVEN PRESS ONE. THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE- AT THE RIGHT TIME IF
YOU COULD GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU MODERATE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CHECK THE LINES
ONE MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM ANY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION S. B. FOUR ELEVEN.
ONCE AGAIN IF THERE ARE ANY
QUICK WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION
PRESS. ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO LINES IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- WE WILL NOW BRING
pMEMBERS DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER LAYERED I HAVE A COMMENT
OF WHEN I WAS. IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY I HAD A COLLEAGUE.
THAT WE USED TO RIDICULE
BECAUSE HE WOULD STAND UP. AT
EVERY HEARING AND DESCRIBE SOME
NEW JOB HE HAD HAD THIS PAST
LIFE WHICH GAVE HIM EXPERIENCE
ON EVERY SINGLE BILL THAT EVER
CAME IN FRONT OF US. AND NOW I
HAVE BECOME THAT PERSON.
BECAUSE IT HAD MY JOB WITH THE
COUNTY BEFORE SELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY I MONITORED. THE HOURS
FOR PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THIS
SITUATION AND WE HAD THESE
PRINT OUTS AND YOU'D GET THREE
ASTERIX ONE MATH WHEN THEY WERE
WITHIN EIGHTY HOURS OF CROSSING
OVER INTO THE- THE NEVER NEVER
LAND. AND NO MATTER HOW
EVERYBODY HAD BEST INTENT.
THERE WAS ALWAYS SOMEBODY THAT
WORKED AN EXTRA HOUR TO OR THE
SUPERVISOR BLEW IT OR THE
SUPERVISOR SWITCHED IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT OR SOMETHING
HAPPENED. AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS BASICALLY SAY. THE
PERSON THAT WAS THE OBJECT OF
THAT SITUATION IS NOT GOING TO
BE PENALIZED WITH AN OUTSIDE I
WOULD SIZE PENALTY THAT IS JUST
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. AND I
KNOW THAT- THE PERSISTENT
ACTUALLY REALLY WANTS TO PUT
EVERY PRESSURE TO KEEP THIS
FROM HAPPENING WALL
LINCOLNSHIRE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO THAT WITHOUT DOING THESE
MASSIVE PENALTIES ON. ON
RETIREES SO I SALUTE- THE
AUTHOR AND IF IT'S APPROPRIATE
NOW I MOVED THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED OPINION CENTER
NEWMAN I CERTAINLY CAN'T SAY IT
BETTER ANY BETTER THAN MY
COLLEAGUES BUT IT WILL SAVE IF
THERE'S ONE LAW COME TO BELIEVE
IN. IT'S A NO GOOD DEED GOES ON
PUNISHED AT SO IT'S NICE TO SEE
THAT THEY WERE SOLVING FOR ONE
OF THOSE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
DAY I ALSO WANT. TO COMMEND THE
SPONSOR MISTER SCHIPPERS NICE
TO SEE YOU I ALSO WANT POSTED-
IF YOU DON'T- MISTER PARIS
ACTUALLY FORMER STATE SENATOR
SHOULD PYRO. AND IT MUST BE
KIND OF ODD FOR YOU TO BE BACK
DOWN THERE- BUT WE SALUTE YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE THEN- AND IT'S
A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU TODAY. NO
WE REALLY TOOK HIM SERIOUSLY TO
YOU SAID THAT. AND JUST FOR
DISCLOSURE PURPOSES THERE WAS
NO SENATOR ON HERE SO. JUST FY
I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
NEWMAN ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. OKAY I JUST HAD ONE
QUESTION AND THAT'S WITH
REGARDS TO- I KNOW THAT THIS
GIVES. INDEPENDENT ASSESSMENT
FOR EACH CASE AS IT COMES DOES
IT HAVE. DOES IT DOES IT HAVE A
LIMITATION FOR CONSIDERATION AS
TO HOW MANY TIMES IT'S- NEEDED
PER EMPLOYEE MOVING FORWARD IF
IT IF IT'S A CONTINUOUS
PRACTICE- WITH THE BILL'S
WRITTEN IT GIVES- CALPERS IN
THE FLEXIBILITY TO. YOU KNOW
THAT TO PUT SOME SORT OF SOME
LIMITATIONS ST I THINK THE
BIGGER ISSUE FOR ME IS JUST.
THE I WOULD LIKE TO SEE-
CALPERS. I MEAN THIS I MEAN
THIS IN A NICE ENOUGH WAY BUT
TO HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME ALONG
THE LINES OF WHAT CENTER ALERT
WAS TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
MONITORING AND CATCHING THESE
THINGS EARLY WHEN THE- WHEN THE
DON'T GET CAUGHT IF NINE
HUNDRED SIXTY HOURS. IT'S JUST
BAD ON IT'S BETTER FOR
EVERYBODY AND ULTIMATELY YOU
SPENT ON PEOPLE WHO COULD
AFFORD AT LEAST TO TRY TO MAKE
IT UP AGAIN- I'VE SEEN IT
HAPPEN IN THE LOCAL RETIREMENT
SYSTEMS EVEN WITH THINGS LIKE.
HAZARD PAY AND COMBAT PAY WERE
PEOPLE'S HAD IT CONTACT THE NOT
BECAUSE THEY DID ANYTHING WRONG
BECAUSE PAYROLL- PAY THEM
BEYOND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
LIMITATIONS WORTH THE TIME SO
I'M NOT. A HERO AND I'M HAPPY
TO. IS A IS A BILL MOVES ALONG-
IT CERTAINLY I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK TO MR SHAPIRO BUT I WOULD
SAY AS A SPONSOR BUT I WOULD
SAY I'M ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO TRY
TO PUT SOME MORE GUARDRAILS.
IN- YOU KNOW IT AS APPROPRIATE-
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER- AT
TIME FEET WE DON'T HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM OUR MEMBERS AND OUR
COMMITTEE- CENTER CORTESE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU FIRST OF ALL LET ME
CONGRATULATE MR SHOULD HIRING
BECAUSE FEAR FORMER STATE
SENATOR THAT MEAN TO YOU. YOU
LARGELY HAVE CONTROL OF YOUR
LIFE BACK. PRESS OTHER THAN
THIS PARTICULAR HEARING TODAY-
ALLEN. WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. AT. WE
WILL GO INTO THE PENSION
COMMENTARY THAT'S- I AND I WANT
TO APOLOGIZE TO FORMER STATE
SENATOR BARBARA PUTTING N THIS
POSITION BEFORE A VOTE. MY
APOLOGIES SIR. THANK YOU INTO
THE WE HAVE A MOTION THAT
SENATOR LAYERED OKAY THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED- THE- THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
LEHRER. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ HI UNDER CORTESE
BY SENATOR- CHAU BOKE HI
EDITOR- CHAU BOCA AND SENATOR
DORADO. SENATOR DORADO ARTS
CENTER LAYERED HI AND- LAYERED
I CENTER NEWMAN HI CENTER
NEWMAN AYE. THE MOTION THE BILL
DOES PASS WITH A FIVE TWO ZERO
FIVE SUPPORT. CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU KOMMENTAR THANK YOU
OF COLLEAGUES. YEAH WE ARE
JURORS THANK YOU.